如果手機跟電腦全部消失
你能忍受幾天？
電腦、手機、AI
科技產品已經成為生活的一部分了
有感的不只是生活品質的提升
連帶的還有台積電、輝達
等等企業的股票
與全球關注度瘋狂飆升
半導體產業
已經是當代全世界
都須了解的課題
過去我們介紹過半導體製程
EDA、晶片法案、氮化鎵
先進製程等許多題目
雖然反應很熱烈
但因為題目比較分散
基礎知識鋪墊的時間比較少
如果缺乏半導體的先備知識
不免還是有點霧裡看花
AMD 的執行長蘇姿丰
在2024年的南方半導體論壇上笑說
台灣是唯一一個
當說出 CoWoS 的時後
大部分的人會知道那是什麼的地方
當然這可能有點誇張
但半導體在台灣以及全世界的重要性
只會增加不會減少
有鑑於此
泛科學展開重大企劃
將透過一系列的節目由淺入深
徹底介紹半導體與半導體產業
從電腦的誕生、晶片戰爭的始末
到當代的半導體大廠角逐
我們將跟隨頂尖科學家與企業的視角
看看半導體到底是什麼？
而台灣又扮演什麼角色呢
這將是一個系列節目
在一切開始之前
我們必須先把時間倒轉200年
看看那個發電機才剛誕生
仍未普及、工廠都還在用蒸汽機的年代
人類是如何透過機械與齒輪
打造人類史上第一台
可以運算的通用計算機
他 對於近代電腦科技的貢獻卓著
也讓他的故事
成為「蒸汽龐克」世界觀的代名詞
他 就是電腦之父－查爾斯·巴貝奇
想像一下
我們的身邊的手機跟電腦都消失了
但我們也不需要他們
因為整個城市
無論是大型工廠的渦輪
飛天汽車、甚至你身上的動力裝甲
都是用一台台的蒸汽機
作為動力源
而這些裝置
都有著複雜的齒輪與機械結構
幾乎能辦到任何事情
不論是要像霍爾的移動城堡
用金屬的四肢移動
還是像調查兵團
靠蒸汽推動立體機動裝置
斬殺數十公尺高的巨人
甚至像《雨果的冒險》中
讓機器人這樣動了起來
只要有蒸汽機與齒輪
OK的啦
這些都是蒸汽龐克世界觀裡的重要元素
而蒸汽龐克這個特殊題材的始祖
是一本1990年代出版
書名叫做《差分機》的小說
書名《差分機》
指的就是電腦之父巴貝奇
最經典的大型機械計算機
在人類的正史上
因為差分機的完成品
實在過於巨大與昂貴
巴貝奇本人其實並未完成它
而小說《差分機》
便以此作為歷史的分支點
假定了巴貝奇成功完成他的差分機
科技發展開始朝不同的方向加速
以蒸汽機、齒輪
還有機械電腦為主的科技
改變了整個世界的社會樣貌
引發了諸多與現代正史
不盡相同的社會與政治議題
可惜 差分機在正史中並沒有被完成
我們錯過了這個充滿蒸汽浪漫的世界
但巴貝奇與差分機的重要性
可見一斑
事實上差分機
以及巴貝奇的另一個重要作品
分析機
也奠定了通用型計算機的發展脈絡
讓巴貝奇獲得電腦之父的尊榮稱號
那麼到底
這個「差分機」是什麼啊？
「差分」是在差什麼？
其實差分機誕生的原因
只是源自於巴貝奇受夠了數學計算
具體來說
應該是他受夠了數學計算時
出現的各種錯誤
在19世紀初還沒有電腦
當然也沒有電子計算機這種東西
巴貝奇本身是一位數學家
日常一般研究用到的四則運算
還能夠用人工計算
但如果牽涉到複雜的指數與對數計算
就沒轍了
如果你在高中數學課
也經歷過指對數的計算
應該會記得
我們需要去查一個東西
叫做「對數表」
對數表上密密麻麻的
但是記錄著事先計算好的數值
例如log1.23=0.0899這樣
這個對數表
其實是透過非常複雜的函數運算得到的
然而 在巴貝奇的年代
對數表當然也是透過「肉手」算出來的
所以最可怕的就是
從不同人手中拿到的對數表
數字竟然都不一樣
而這不只是因為人為計算錯誤
也是因為數字實在過多
導致繕寫以及印刷時產生誤植
雖然錯的可能只是小數點後的一個數字
但是經過漫長的運算後
就會出現極大的誤差
這看著不同版本的對數表
這時候巴貝奇心中
小鹿亂撞、心花怒放
他想
現在許多機械
都不再使用人力跟獸力了
改用蒸汽機推動
那算盤、計算尺
這些透過機械進行運算的數學工具
也已經有了數百年的歷史
這個我是不是也能來做一台
全自動計算機
屏除所有的人為計算疏失呢
也就在這個時候
數學家德普羅尼提出的想法
深深影響了巴貝奇
德普羅尼在當時一樣深受對數表的困擾
但是要重新計算一張對數表
又曠日廢時
最後
他在亞當·斯密的《國富論》中
找到了答案
也就是工業化的核心理念 「分工」
如果一件複雜的工作
可以拆成多個步驟
那麼流水線上的每個工人或機械
只要處理眼前的任務就好了
不僅流程上變順暢了
每項任務的工作複雜度
也會大幅降低
德普羅尼受到啟發
發展了一套方法
宣稱 可以讓計算對數
和製造大頭針一樣簡單
核心概念其實很簡單明瞭
那就是 所有複雜的運算
都可以簡化為加法的延伸
例如3乘以2 就等於3+3
不論是三角函數或是對數
最後經由高階數學家的拆分
都可以變為一大串的加法
而這些簡單但數量龐大的加法工作
則可以讓所有會基礎加法的
「人類電腦」來完成
甚至不需要太高的教育程度
這個計算方法其實影響深遠
在我們現在的半導體產業中
也能看到它的影子
例如晶片中就算是再複雜的計算
幾乎都能用無數個NAND或NOR邏輯閘
來拼湊而成
這部份我們之後來談
總之
巴貝奇參考了德普羅尼計算對數的差分法
也研究了17世紀由帕斯卡發明
只用齒輪就能計算加法的帕斯卡計算器
準備透過機械的力量
來讓計算對數這件事自動化
但是
為什麼用來計算對數的方法
叫做差分法呢
計算的機器要叫做差分機呢
原來 依照德普羅尼發展的步驟
所有的對數計算
最後都會被拆解成複雜的多項式
如果要讓「人類電腦」
計算出多項式的結果
就要使用「差分法」來進行計算
舉例來說
如果有一個多項式寫作f(x)=3x+1
就代表我們希望計算出
帶入不同x值時的f(x)
例如當x=1
那麼等號左邊的f(x)
就等於3乘以1再加上1
答案是4
那如果x=2呢
雖然我們可以馬上算出
答案等於3乘以2再加1等於7
但是對差分機來說
它只是齒輪跟機器
沒有那麼聰明
因此我們需要回頭看這個公式
找出其中的規則
那麼我們就會推斷出每當x增加1
從1變成2
或是從2變成3
整個f(x)的答案就會增加3
接著把這個簡化後的簡單規則
告訴差分機
這樣一來
當差分機要計算x=2的答案時
他只要計算f(1)+3
就能得到7這個答案
以此類推 即使它不懂乘法
也可以算出x=任意正整數時的答案
當多項式進入到二次方以上
就更加複雜了
例如如果函數f(x)=x的平方加1
那麼根據計算的結果
x每增加1
f(x)的差會是2x+1
但是這個「差」因為裡面也有x
所以也會隨著x變動
因此要再計算第二階的差
讓差分機能計算出
x從1到2時
增加的差是3
但是x從2變成3時
差也會跟著變動 變成5
好 關於計算就講到這邊
如果對差分法還有興趣的朋友
請到泛科學留下你的想法或疑問
如果大家真的很有興趣
我們再透過社群貼文
或是短影音繼續算下去
這邊最重要的概念只有一個
就是只要透過計算「差」
再複雜的多項式計算
最後都能換成一個一個的加法運算
並且透過差分機來完成
事實上巴貝奇在1822 年
也完成了一個擁有三個立軸的小型樣本
這個樣本的三個立軸
分別代表三個加法器
動力則還得靠手來轉動
但是這個發明
已經引起了英國政府的興趣
並且願意花錢投資
巴貝奇也在此時
正式幫這個機器取名為
「差分機」
那既然初期成果還不錯
也獲得了投資
為什麼最後差分機還是沒有完成呢？
難道
這跟尼古拉特斯拉的死亡
是為了終結死光開發的都市傳說一樣
差分機被阻止
也是有人暗中阻擋我們
走向蒸汽龐克的世界線嗎
應該......
不是
差分機看似強大
但可以想像到的是
當要計算更複雜的多項式時
就需要更多階層的運算
意味著差分機需要更多的齒輪結構
根據差分機1號的設計圖
差分機完成後
預計會是一台寬2.3公尺
高2.6公尺
擁有2萬5千個零件
重達四噸的龐然巨獸
但最麻煩的在於
當時的金屬加工技術
還無法穩定地量產差分機要求的元件
因此英國政府投入的成本暴增
從1823年的1700英鎊
1842年已經來到十倍的1萬7千英鎊
依照當時的物價
1萬7千英鎊足以打造兩艘英國戰艦
而巴貝奇的差分機卻還看不到成品
最後 整個計畫終於被迫放棄
但巴貝奇的夢想可沒有熄滅
此時的他決定投入研究另一台
更加厲害的計算機
「分析機」
他希望這台分析機
不僅能做到差分機能做的事
還能完成任何種類的計算
成為世上第一台真正的通用計算機
究竟巴貝奇能成功嗎
電腦到底是誰發明的？
不只是個人電腦與手機
現在所有可見的穿戴裝置、電子設備
裡頭都含有大大小小的微電腦
但我們知道這是因為半導體
已經能夠做到好小好小
所以一片小小的晶片就能完成無數工作
那麼在半導體被發現之前
我們到底是怎麼只靠幾根玻璃管
甚至是幾顆電磁鐵跟線圈
就做出人類最早的電子計算機呢
電腦這種足以挑戰人類智慧的機械
究竟是怎麼冒出來的？
在上一集我們提到
現代「電腦」的先驅
是19世紀英國發明家查爾斯·巴貝奇
以及他的重要發明「差分機」
甚至世界上的第一本蒸氣龐克小說
就是以《差分機》作為書名
描繪如果差分機真的被做出來
那麼現在的世界
很有可能是以蒸汽機作為動力
以機械齒輪完成所有的工具活動
跟電腦計算
我們現在知道
差分機的製作過於困難
計畫被放棄了
因此我們沒有進入蒸氣龐克的未來
但當時的巴貝奇可沒有就此放棄啊
他轉身投入另一項重要發明
分析機
雖然分析機的知名度不如差分機
但分析機實際上才是通用計算機的起點
是那個足以讓巴貝奇
被稱為「電腦之父」的重要發明
巴貝奇心想
差分機能做的事情
也只有透過差分法進行多項式運算
本質上還是個任務專一性很高的機械
他的理想是
做出一台通用計算機
可以處理所有的運算
但這也不難啊
回顧一下德普羅尼的核心思想
「所有數學計算都能簡化為加法」
就揭示了這件事是可以達成的
剩下最難的部分就是機械的結構設計
巴貝奇最後設計出來的分析機
比差分機大上了一圈
裏頭包含著
加法、乘法、差分等各種運算單元
可以完成所有計算任務
這台分析機預計由蒸汽機驅動
是個10公尺寬
長30公尺的巨大機械集合體
為了操作這個複雜的機械
巴貝奇引入打洞卡的概念
透過打洞卡上面的「程式」
分析機可以選擇不同的運算單元
來進行運算
這一部分
人類史上第一位程式設計師
愛達·勒芙蕾絲扮演了相當重要的角色
有興趣的觀眾
可以參考泛科學網站上的文章
除此之外
為了讓分析機不會因為遇到複雜的算式
而無止盡增加位元和元件數量
巴貝奇想到了「暫存的概念」
也就是完成部分計算的數字
會先存起來
再丟入下一次的計算
他將分析機視為兩大主要構造的結合體
用來暫存資料的「store」
以及用來運算的「mill」
這 Store 就是儲存的英文
至於為什麼運算是 mill 研磨呢？
歡迎知道的朋友跟我們分享一下
以現在的電腦架構來看
整台分析機便有了作為記憶體的store
作為算術邏輯單元的mill
以及作為輸入跟輸出指令的打洞卡
與現代電腦常使用的馮諾伊曼架構
十分類似
並且只要有打洞卡跟無限的時間
分析機就能完成任何計算
具備「圖靈完備性」
是一台貨真價實的圖靈機
大家要知道
分析機的初步設計
在1837年由巴貝奇提出
而圖靈提出的「圖靈機」概念
是1936年
整整一百年之後啊
遺憾的是
巴貝奇的設計超越同代人類想像
不僅當時的科學技術跟不上
導致研發成本暴增
現實也十分殘酷地
宣告差分機與分析機的失敗
大量的齒輪與機械結構
限制了運算的速度
如果採用德普羅尼的差分法
找大量的「人類電腦」
來處理複雜的加法運算
還更有效率 成本也更低
這讓我想到前陣子也有新聞說
人類還不用擔心被 AI 取代
原因是人類比較便宜.......
嗯
巴貝奇過世的18年後
1888年 尼古拉特斯拉
發明了高頻交流發電機
人類正式邁入電氣時代
然而利用電磁元件打造的電腦
例如後面要介紹的繼電器、真空管
甚至是現在的電晶體
雖然也是用於「計算」的核心
卻與用機械齒輪打造的分析機
有著運作原理以及硬體材料上本質的區別
巴貝奇他這些超越時代的想法
並沒有對後續的電腦科技發展
產生深遠的影響
甚至現在大家提到「電腦之父」
第一個想到的
也往往不是巴貝奇
而是百年後的
真正帶著全世界電腦科學
向前邁進的艾倫·圖靈
巴貝奇真的生錯世界線了！
如果要說第一台真正吃電的「電腦」
是怎麼問世的
我們要將時間線向後推到19世紀末期
關於電腦的故事
我們要從IBM開始說起
1890年
統計學家赫爾曼·何樂禮
接到了來自美國政府的一項重要任務
他必須負責全國的人口普查工作
這包含要調查全國超過5千萬人的年紀
性別、地址、人種、失業幾個月
是否參加過南北戰爭等等
多達25種資料
如果是你 你會怎麼做呢？
事實上 在自動化機械出現之前
這個龐大任務只能全部交由人工作業
所以上一次
也就是1880年的人口普查工作
竟然花了八年才完成
1880年的十年之後
美國人口從5000萬成長到6300萬
照這個速度下去
10年一次的人口普查
可能要花上超過10年才能完成
這這這 準時就過時啊
肩負重任的何樂禮左思右想
無獨有偶的跟蒸氣龐克之父巴貝奇
看上了一個相同的東西
它既可以儲存資料
又讓機械看得懂
那就是打洞卡
只是跟巴貝奇
還在使用蒸氣與齒輪的年代不一樣
19世紀末期
發電機、繼電器等等基本電路元件
都已經問世了
因此這個打洞卡
其實是一張讓電路也看得懂的資料卡
何樂禮設計出一台裝置
上下是分開的電極
中間則夾著絕緣的打洞紙或打洞卡
當機械向下壓時
上方針狀的電極
就會遇到打洞卡而停止
又或是穿過洞口
與下方裝有水銀的電極接觸
讓電流導通
最後電流
透過繼電器給予指針一個短脈衝
讓指針刻度加1
在這台新機器
也就是「何樂禮電力製表系統」的幫助下
即使在人口增長超過20%的十年後
調查時間仍然能夠縮短
從8年縮減為6年
雖然還是要花上數年
但已經證明自動化機械
能縮短工作時間並減少人力需求
同時 因為是交由機械統計
資料的可信度也比人工高上許多
這項偉業
也讓何樂禮被認為是
現代機械數據處理之父
人口普查是一份非常大的案子
為了每次都能順利接下這個案子
何樂禮不斷改良它的製表系統
同時創立了製表機械公司 TMC
這間公司在1911年時
跟其它四家公司
合併成「計算製表記錄公司」CTR
CTR 又在 1924 年
改名為萬國商業機械公司
也就是「IBM」
雖然有了用機械處理數據的第一例
但接下來的一段時間
類似的機械
都是針對特定的問題做設計
如果要做出一台
真正的通用型電子計算機
那我們得先向上一集提到的
德普羅尼與巴貝奇學習
將所有任務簡化為單一語言
而成功創造出電子語言
被視為數位計算機理論
跟數位電路設計理論創始人的
是一位來自麻省理工學院的天才
克勞德·夏農
在「何樂禮電力製表系統」裡
使用到的繼電器
是一個早在製表系統發明的50年前
就被發明的小元件
它就是一個簡單的開關
加上一個電磁鐵
透過電磁鐵的啟動或不啟動
物理性地控制開關的閉合
所謂情人眼裡出西施
繼電器終於在發明後的100年
遇到了它命中註定的情人
在天才夏農看來
繼電器才不只是一個開關而已
而是一個可以表現布林代數
充滿無限可能性的元件
所謂的布林代數
就是用來進行集合運算
和邏輯運算的代數結構
簡單來說
就是在邏輯課裡面提到的
和、或、AND、OR、交集、聯集
非p則q 這些東西
舉例來說
如果我們在電路中串聯兩個繼電器
那麼想一下就知道
只要上一個繼電器沒有接上
就不會有電流通過
只有當兩個繼電器都接上時
才會有電流通過
也就是說
兩個繼電器就相當於一個AND gate
你很快就能推論出
如果我們改將兩個繼電器並聯
就會變成一個OR gate
因為只要有一個繼電器是接上的
電流就能通過
以此類推
可以做出複雜的邏輯閘結構
值得留意的是
繼電器用電磁鐵這種線路之外的構造
來作為開關的概念
與我們之後會提到的
當今電晶體中
閘極的功能是一模一樣的喔
1937年 年僅21歲
就讀麻省理工學院研究所的克勞德·夏農
發表了論文
《繼電器和開關電路的符號分析》
詳細說明如何透過繼電器
拼湊出帶有複雜邏輯運算的開關電路
至此
電腦的前置科技樹都已經開發完成了
夏農發表論文的兩年後
1939年
世界迎來了一件天翻地覆的衝擊
第二次世界大戰正式開打
軍事的角逐
當然無可避免地延伸到科技上的競爭
第一台電腦
就誕生在這風雨飄搖的年代
而那個鼎鼎大名的男人
馮諾伊曼也在這個時間點出手了
在半導體元件
根本就還沒誕生的年代
第一台全自動化計算機
是怎麼做出來的
亂世出英雄
從第一世界大戰
到第二次世界大戰
隨著戰爭規模擴大
電腦的需求也跟著提高
在電影《奧本海默》中
被遺忘的科學家馮諾伊曼
卻是電腦發展歷史中
關鍵到不能再關鍵的人物
第一台真正的全自動化電腦
是怎麼誕生的
伴隨電腦科技一起誕生的「真空管」
是如何開創了整個電子時代呢
第一台全自動化的計算機ASCC
是IBM的傑作之一
ASCC的開發是由哈佛博士生
霍華德·艾肯提出
IBM來完成
這台電子計算機最大的特點
就是資料輸入
到得到輸出的過程中
完全不需要人為操作
在那辛苦地將上一個步驟的打洞卡
送到下一步驟的運算單元去
而它所使用的核心元件
就是繼電器
最後完成的計算機
長16.6公尺
高2.4公尺
76萬個元件
重達4.5噸
大約是一頭大河馬的體重
然而這台電子計算機
卻迎來意料之外的風波
在捐贈儀式上
艾肯竟然獨攬功勞
將自己列為ASCC的唯一發明者
完全不提IBM的任何一位工程師
IBM
憤而與哈佛解除合作關係
哈佛大學也和艾肯
重新將ASCC命名為哈佛一型
除了合作破局外
哈佛一型實際上的成績單
並不漂亮
這源自於它與現代PC中
常見的運作架構並不一樣
現代電腦
主要採用的是「馮諾伊曼架構」
資料與程式
都預先載到記憶單元
才開始進行運算
相比之下
哈佛一號將程式與數據分開
不共用記憶單元
每次動作
都要重新讀取不同記憶體
因此運算所需的耗時較長
這個架構又被稱為「哈佛架構」
雖然馮諾伊曼架構贏得了勝利
而且主宰了
未來數十年間的家用主機
但近年你可能也聽過
用在Mac與智慧型手機上的ARM架構
其實就是哈佛架構
準確地說
是「改進後」的哈佛架構
來個絕地大反攻
這個等之後談到電腦架構時
我們再來詳細介紹
但在1940年代
世界上第一台通用型電子計算機
能快速實用
還真的得靠馮諾伊曼這位大師的幫助
第一台通用型電子計算機
由戰爭孕育而生
1941年12月7日
日本襲擊珍珠港
美國正式參戰
為了讓電子計算機的效能再提升
必須換掉本質上
還是透過磁鐵進行機械開關
反應速度還不夠快的繼電器
連一刻都沒有為繼電器的死亡哀悼
立刻趕到戰場的是
真空管
真空管是一個
抽氣至幾乎真空的玻璃結構
就像是個小燈泡
陽極是金屬片
陰極則是包著燈絲的金屬片
加熱陰極的燈絲後
外圍的陰極金屬片
就會產生游離電子
並被吸引到陽極
這相當於電子流的移動
也就是說當真空管正常運作
就相當於電路導通
那要如何安裝上開關呢
很簡單
就在陰極跟陽極中間
裝入一個柵欄
又稱柵極
因為電子帶負電
只要將柵極通上負電壓
電子就會無法靠近
而使電流下降
陰極 陽極 再加上柵極
因此被稱為三極管
透過電壓操作
反應速度比繼電器快上許多
實際上三極管
同時也是世上第一款電子放大器
宣告了人類電子時代的正式到來
真空管為何是電子時代的始祖呢
在真空管的發展路徑中
其實兩個不盡然相同的發展路線
一個是「數位」邏輯閘
另一個則是「類比」訊號的放大器
這兩條路線都非常重要
數位這條路線是我們現在熟悉的
利用邏輯閘的開與關來表達0、1
用一連串的0、1
來代表我們要傳達的資訊與程式
類比呢
類比指的是那些波形連續的訊號
例如聲波 電磁波
類比訊號中不會出現0、1
通常就是一個連續波形
舉例來說
你要從廣播電台發送訊號
就會直接透過廣播台上的麥克風
將聲波轉換為電訊號
再透過「調幅」等方式
轉換為帶有資訊的
電磁波訊號進行發送
而遠離電台的我們
只要拉開收音機的天線
接收電磁波訊號
再經由放大器放大
推動喇叭
就能將訊號還原回我們能聽到的聲波
而這個過程
完全不會出現0、1這種位元
當然
現在你手機裡
電腦裡的音樂檔案
都是用數位的方式紀錄
而從你我嘴巴發出的聲波
並不會因為科技進步而變成000111
因此如何將聲波
這種類比訊號轉為電子訊號
又或是將電子訊號
重新轉為類比訊號
透過喇叭播出
而且避免訊號轉換時的失真
這又是另一個大課題
這部分就我們未來再講
在類比訊號中
放大器扮演很重要的角色
1898年
義大利工程師馬可尼
發送了一個無線電波
橫跨了英吉利海峽
完成了跨國的無線電訊號傳輸
原本傳遞電報
還只能透過實體電線
沒想到一下子
訊號竟然可以不需要硬體設備
就傳送到遠方
無疑是重大創舉
但當時還沒有「放大器」這種東西
想接收無線電波
多半是用礦石收音機
這種不需要電源
直接靠接收到的電磁波
來運作的收音機
如果你覺得
這種不用電源
也能運作的收音機很神奇
可以到泛科學YT頻道複習這一集
要讓遠方的家庭也能收到訊息
看來
就只能無止盡地
增加廣播電台的功率
而真空管放大器的出現
卻打破了這個限制
前面我們介紹過
真空管的構造與運作原理
我們會加熱真空管陰極的燈絲
大量電子因此移動到陽極
同時電路也因此導通
此時
只要我們在中間加入一個柵欄
就能開關這個電路
每當我們在柵欄上施加負電壓
電子就會因為同性相斥而無法靠近
讓電流中斷
達成「關閉電路」的效果
但實際上
調整柵極的電壓
並不會一口氣關閉整條電子高速公路
而是施加越多的負電壓
就有越少的電子能通過
如果負電壓沒施加那麼高
就能有部分電子穿越
也就是說
真空管陽極接收到的電子數量
是波動的
而不是只有０跟１兩種狀態
所以如果我們在柵極
輸入一個波形訊號
輸出的訊號也會是波形的
這個特性如何用來做放大器呢
我們如果收到一個非常微弱的訊號
只要先準備一個真空管
在兩側通上更大的電壓
再將手上的微弱訊號送到柵極
那麼
我們在陽極收到的電子訊號
就會與原始訊號長得非常像
但是強度被放大數百倍
當然你應該會注意到
輸入和輸出的訊號是反向的
也就是輸入明明是增加電壓
輸出卻是反變小
因此這個電路通常還需要加入其他設計
例如負回饋電路
或是相位補償電路來調整相位
1906年
發明家李·德富雷斯特
創造了第一顆三極真空管
至此無線電
廣播
電視科技開始加速
真空管開始隨處可見
1914年一戰爆發
無線電通訊作為決勝兵器亮相
二戰到冷戰結束期間
廣播戰成為各國競相使用的心戰武器
針對廣播站與廣播內容的干擾
開闢了另一個特別的戰場
從20世紀初到二戰這段時間
相比發展緩慢
只有大型實驗室才能用上的電腦
類比電路
電子學的運用
可以說是遍地開花
那真空管電腦的結局是什麼呢
1943年
第一台用真空管
取代繼電器的電子數值積分計算機
ENIAC
開始建造
歷時兩年半才全數完成
最後用上了1萬8000根真空管
重達27公噸
有如三頭成年大象
即便如此
它每秒能執行高達5000次加法
遠超當代其他計算機
然而 ENIAC
在1946年正式亮相時
已經是二戰結束後的隔年
它並沒有展現實力的機會
但ENIAC的存在
卻吸引了那個男人的目光
參與曼哈頓計畫的馮諾伊曼
需要進行大量計算
因此也投入 ENIAC 的開發
他發現
ENIAC 的使用
需要數萬片的卡片
進行輸入與輸出
遇上複雜的任務
需要耗費數週的時間才能完成
在參與 ENIAC 多次的升級之後
馮諾伊曼在1944年
加入了下一台電子計算機
EDVAC的開發
1945年
一份101頁的報告書
詳細記載了EDVAC的設計
這份由馮諾伊曼撰寫的
《EDVAC報告書的第一份草案》
也是馮諾伊曼架構的
第一次正式亮相
馮諾伊曼架構中
提出了五個核心元件
輸入設備
輸出設備
運算邏輯單元
記憶體
控制單元
其中
運算邏輯單元負責計算
記憶體負責儲存資料與操作指令
輸入與輸出設備
負責將程式與資料
送進記憶體與紀錄結果
控制單元則負責協調各元件的運作
這套架構的最大特點
在於執行不同程式時
不再需要改動機器的實體結構
要先執行的程式
會先放在記憶體中
需要運用時
再從記憶體中抓出來
因此只要確保
先將程式都先塞入記憶體
不論是加減乘除
還是微積分計算
一台電腦就能完成
馮諾伊曼架構一用就是數十年
至今雖然出現挑戰者
但也仍然占有重要地位
真空管帶領電腦發展到這邊
創造了一整個電子世代
但是這樣的成果
卻仍然改變不了
最終被替換掉的命運
真空管笨重
壽命不長的致命傷
讓科學家們開始尋找
能替代真空管的
下一個三極體材料
半導體為何是21世紀
最重要的產業呢
要回答這個問題
不能只看此時此刻
回到1956年
當年諾貝爾物理學獎
頒給了三位美國人
威廉·蕭克利
約翰·巴丁
沃爾特·布拉頓
以表彰他們對
「半導體的研究和發現電晶體效應」
這一句話
揭開了一個新時代的序幕
在獲獎的九年前
1947年12月16號
世界上第一顆電晶體誕生了
電子科學從真空管
一腳踏入了電晶體時代
笨重的真空管
汰換成反應快
體積小的電晶體
讓世界天翻地覆
現在小小的晶片
已經能塞入上百億個電晶體
運行無數的任務與程式
也為半導體產業
帶來無可限量的產值
要徹底了解
半導體這個巨大無比的產業
就得先來看看這個產業
是如何崛起的
世界上第一顆電晶體
又是怎麼誕生的
上一集我們提到
第一台通用型電子計算機的誕生
要歸功於真空管的發明
真空管可以透過改變閘極的電壓
控制從陰極流到陽極的電子數量
簡單來說
就像是一個
可以控制水流大小的水龍頭
而大大小小的水龍頭串在一起
就可以完成複雜的邏輯電路
甚至是數學運算
但真空管笨重
壽命不長的致命傷
讓電腦科技的成長受到了限制
畢竟當電腦變得大台
真空管數量增加
就會面臨每天都有真空管壞掉
每天都要修電腦
什麼事都不能做的窘境
這逼迫科學家勢必要尋找新的材料
他們要尋找的目標
必須跟真空管一樣
具備三個電極
並且
我們能透過
改變其中一個電極的電壓
控制另外兩個電極的電流
這種構造
在廣義上被稱為「三極體」
這些三極體必須滿足兩個條件
一是電子或電流的流向
應該具有「單向性」
只會朝一個方向流動
例如三極管的電子
只會從陰極流向陽極
二是可以
透過外加的電場
來控制這個電流
例如三極管
可以改變閘極的電壓
來調控電流
一切出自於某個巧合
1940年
貝爾實驗室的工程師
羅素·奧爾
在測量矽的電阻時
偶然發現其中一塊純矽
在燈光的照射下
竟然出現了電壓
這明明只是一塊絕緣體矽啊
仔細調查才發現
這塊純矽中間有條裂縫
而且成分不純
而關鍵就是這個不純
在裂縫的一側
似乎摻了少許的磷
另一側則摻了少許的硼
這顆小小的矽石
就是矽半導體
在世人前的首次亮相
「半導體」的概念
在這之前其實早就存在了
但湊巧發現透過摻雜元素
就能做出矽半導體
還是第一次
根據元素週期表
很快就能大致推測出原因
矽在週期表位列第四族
代表矽原子最外層的價電子
有四顆
可以想像成有四支空出來的手
可以和周圍的原子起作用
例如在純矽晶體中
這四隻手的每隻手
都會和周邊的另一顆矽原子手牽手
最後
當一堆矽原子都互相手牽手
就會組合成一個巨大且穩固的結構
因為這些手都是電子
本來是拿來導電的
現在手空不出來
矽也就無法導電
是個標準的絕緣體
但如果這時候出現不速之客
一個有五隻手的磷突然插了進來
那麼情況就不一樣了
磷會多出一支手
也就是多出一顆相對自由的電子
反過來說
如果摻了只有三隻手的硼
就會有一顆矽的一個電子
找不到人牽手
形成一個等待其他電子來作伴的
「電洞」
當這兩塊半導體材料
距離很近並且照光
摻磷矽半導體上的電子
就會獲得能量而跳躍到
旁邊渴求電子的摻硼矽半導體
他們很快將含磷
帶自由電子的半導體
取為n型半導體(negative)
含硼而出現電子空缺「電洞」的
則為p型半導體(positive)
看來
滿足三極體第一個條件
也就是電子或電流的流向
必須具有「單向性」的材料
找到了
接下來
貝爾實驗室的天才同事們
威廉·蕭克利
沃爾特·布拉頓
約翰·巴丁相繼加入研究
準備開發使用半導體材料的三極體
在奧爾發現矽半導體的7年後
1947年
第一顆電晶體
終於在貝爾實驗室中誕生了
這顆原初電晶體的體積可不小
整個裝置
差不多等於一個放在桌上的馬克杯
在靠近桌面的金屬基板上
放有一塊n型鍺半導體
鍺跟矽一樣
都是最外層有四顆電子的材料
可以透過放入磷 硼
或其他三族與五族元素
來製成p型與n型半導體
在n型鍺半導體的上方
懸吊著一個三角形塑膠塊
表面則貼上一層薄薄的金箔
並且在三角型的尖端
輕輕割上一刀
分成左右兩片互不接觸
但距離極近的金箔
最後讓三角形與兩片金箔
輕輕接觸鍺的表面
第一顆電晶體就完成了
它是怎麼運作的呢
訊號輸入的地方
是電晶體左側
接上正極的「射極」
大量電子的出入口
則是右方作為集極的金箔
以及下方作為基極的n型半導體
當我們在射極施加正電壓
電壓會在鍺的表面
產生許多電洞
讓鍺從n型變為p型
這個影響範圍並不大
但是一旁的金箔
也就是集極靠得非常近
因此對集極來說
它的周圍也出現了許多電洞
此時在集極接上更大的負電壓
電洞就可以經由集極離開
產生更大的電流
達到訊號放大的效果
雖然成果很成功
但有人開心不太起來
蕭克利作為實驗室主管與物理學天才
為這個計畫帶來諸多的想法
功不可沒
可是最後第一顆電晶體誕生的時候
實際上蕭克利並不在場
甚至這顆電晶體
並不是使用蕭克利的設計
最後的完成品
可以說是布拉頓與巴丁
透過不斷實驗
摸索出來的全新設計
最後蕭克利發現
專利書上竟然沒有出現自己的名字
甚至自己最早提出的設計
也被其他人搶去了專利
在這顆電晶體的發表記者會上
記者們拍下了一張經典的照片
蕭克利依然坐在中間
左右分別為巴丁和布拉頓
看起來是三個人的共同功勞
然而表面真善美
現實滿臉血
記者此時此刻還完全不知道
蕭克利並沒有被列為發明人這件事
事情還沒完呢
更狗血的是
在場也沒有人知道
蕭克利為了證明自身的價值
早在記者會兩天前
竟然拿了他自己構想出來的全新設計
申請了專利
而比起貝爾實驗室的第一顆電晶體
蕭克利這項專利的重要性更為傑出
被後世認為是近代電子學上
最具革命性的發明
它就是赫赫有名的
雙極性接面型電晶體
BJT
這項發明實在的證明了
蕭克利對世界的巨大貢獻
蕭克利還真的成功扳回一城
只能說
一張看似光鮮亮麗
和樂融融的照片背後
有多少勾心鬥角的劇情
真的沒人猜得到啊
其實
三人一起發明的第一顆電晶體
缺點不能說很多
簡直是令人想翻桌
算上機械支撐結構
大小大概有一個馬克杯那麼大
而且
其中兩個電極
還是兩片靠得非常近的金箔
輕輕地貼在鍺半導體上
金箔的末端則和鍺金屬輕輕接觸
這樣的電晶體構造稱為
點接觸電晶體
實際上
跟我們現在常見的電晶體結構
長得非常不一樣
因為它的結構脆弱而且不易製造
如果遇到晃動與碰撞
射極與集極的位置偏了一些
就有可能導致電特性改變
而讓電晶體報銷
蕭克利決定設計出
更加完美的電晶體
來證明自己的實力
他重新改良一開始提出
卻沒有被完成的想法
做出了一個
由三塊半導體材料組成的電晶體
這塊電晶體有著三明治結構
兩塊n型半導體在兩側
p型半導體被夾在中間
對應三極體的三個電極
中間的p型半導體是基極
兩旁的n型半導體
則作為射極與集極
這個結構不僅單純
製作上也比點接觸式簡單
材料也不再只能用鍺
而可以用地球地殼中
第二豐富的元素
矽
這就是當今非常重要的電晶體之一
雙極性接面型電晶體
BJT（bipolar junction transistor）
下一集
我們就要來深入聊聊
BJT
為何足以改變世界
以及另一個對現在晶片來說
最重要的電晶體結構
MOSFET
又是如何出現的
還有
綜觀蕭克利的整個人生
可以看的出來
他自尊心與野心極強
對於功勞被搶走這件事的在意程度
遠超一般人
雖然他本人
也確實有對應實力的才氣
在台積電出現之前
是它孕育出了電晶體
還讓半導體產業成長茁壯
它至今仍是科技重鎮
它就是 矽谷
那個為世界帶來電晶體
改變世界的科學家
威廉·蕭克利
就是讓矽產業在此扎根的人物
不僅開創了晶片時代
還影響了包括
摩爾定律提出者
高登摩爾在內的
多位重要科學家與企業家
然而矽谷之祖蕭克利
竟也被後人稱為矽谷之恥
矽谷的崛起過程
可以說就是蕭克利
與他的門徒們
經歷背叛 競爭
用血與矽所打造出來的
為什麼半導體產業
會從矽谷開始
成為改變世界的重要科技
這其中發生了哪些故事呢
1947年
世界上第一顆電晶體
在貝爾實驗室中誕生
人類終於準備進入半導體時代
但上一集我們提到
貝爾實驗室中的第一顆
「點接觸電晶體」
就像是實驗室中剛拼湊出
勉強能運作的雛型
體積龐大
機械結構又脆弱
怎麼看都沒辦法
把大量的「點接觸電晶體」
同時放進電腦中
而電晶體之父蕭克利
提出了簡單穩定的架構
雙極性電晶體
BJT
這塊電晶體有著三明治結構
兩塊n型半導體在兩側
p型半導體被夾在中間
對應三極體的三個電極
中間的p型半導體是基極
兩旁的n型半導體
則作為射極與集極
這個三明治結構單純
製作也比點接觸式簡單
而且三明治的結構
創造出了另一種可能性
n型半導體因為摻了五族元素
會帶有許多電子
p型半導體因為摻了三族元素
因此會有許多電洞
但p型半導體被夾在中間
所以兩邊n型半導體的電子
都會向中間流去
與p型半導體的電洞結合
這人與人要是不合
但電子跟電洞結合不完全
則是好事
因為上集我們提過
電子和電洞的存在
就是因為摻雜元素與旁邊的矽原子
價電子數目對不上
才讓原本是絕緣體的矽
產生了可以活動的電子與電洞
產生導電性
一旦電子找上電洞
兩個人手牽手形成穩定配對
反而又回到安定
不易導電的狀態
會在PN接面形成
一塊不易導電的空乏區
空乏區的存在
會阻止兩邊更遠的電子電洞結合
因此最終這個載子流動行為會停止
自然就不會有電流持續產生
這時基極
也就是中間p型半導體的位置
就是掌握整個電流開關的關鍵
基極會從這薄薄一層的p型半導體
施加正電壓
電洞則順著加大電場的方向
朝射極流去
這個突然加入的電壓
可以順利在射極與基極間的PN介面
打開電子通道
大量的電子會開始
湧入基極所在的p型半導體
但這層p型半導體厚度非常薄
因此更多的電子在進入基極時
並不會停下腳步
而是逕直地朝向集極移動
最後大部分的電子都會到達集極
而不是基極
達到電訊號放大的效果
簡單來說
這就像是一個大房間內卡滿了人
有兩扇最大
可以同時容納多人通行的
前門與後門在兩側
房間的側面
還有一個工作人員專用的小門
雖然這個小門還是能讓人進出
但它最主要的作用
就是讓工作人員
可以出來管制秩序
疏通人流
只要人流成功疏通
那麼最大的進出口
還是在前門和後門
而不是這個工作人員出口
再以先前提到的真空管
來做比較的話
基極就是對應中間的閘極
陰極與陽極
則對應射極與集極
這個構造相對簡單
但改變基極的厚度
與三塊半導體的摻雜濃度
也會大大影響結果
例如一般來說基極厚度
必須遠小於電子的擴散長度
讓電子能輕易跨過基極到達集極
射極則需要有最高的摻雜濃度
好將更多的電子
推向基極與集極
蕭克利發展的這種電晶體
相對於點接觸電晶體
被稱為接面型電晶體
擁有更大的PN接面
因此製作上較簡單
電晶體也較堅固
耐得起機械運作的晃動與撞擊
但BJT的誕生終究只是開幕表演
儘管是一個極其華麗
且重要的開幕表演
很快的
不習慣在別人底下做事的蕭克利
終於離開貝爾實驗室
準備向世界證明
他能在世界掀起波瀾
而矽谷也將因為
蕭克利創業的這個決定而誕生
矽谷為什麼叫矽谷
其實矽谷並不是該地的正式名稱
一切的開頭都要追溯到1951年
史丹佛研究園區的建立
當時史丹佛大學的校長
獨具慧眼的弗雷德里克·特曼
決定在學校的附近
建立史丹佛工業園區
這是第一次有大學成立工業園區
也是世上第一個
以科技為主軸的工業園區
特曼的貢獻絕對功不可沒
在蕭克利來到這個園區以前
特曼就已拿出
相當於現在1萬美元的資本
鼓勵他的兩個學生
在自家車庫創業
這兩個學生名為威廉·惠利特
與大衛·普克德
他們取各自名字的第一個字
創了一間公司
就叫做「惠普」
而這個車庫作為矽谷發源地
同時也作為矽谷
「車庫創業」的精神象徵
現在已被美國列入國家史蹟名錄
1956年
特曼與蕭克利多次見面
終於說服蕭克利將他的新公司
設立在史丹佛研究園區
也讓「矽」產業在此生根發芽
新公司的名字就叫做
蕭克利半導體實驗室
但當時不如現在有那麼多企業
與大學科系在研究半導體
蕭克利花了不少工夫
才湊齊第一批員工
其中則包含了
未來將被蕭克利稱為「八叛徒」的八人
高登摩爾就是其中一人
隨著身分從主管變為老闆
蕭克利他乖戾 固執 蠻橫的特性
更加彰顯
逐漸壓的員工們喘不過氣
接下來的波折之曲折複雜
不是拍個五季 62 集就能完成的
想要體驗原汁原味劇情的
可以去看這本《蕭克利與八叛徒》
包你看完一定滿意
我們舉幾個這本書裡面提到的案例
來跟你分享
首先這群理應
是世上最聰明的「菁英」
入職前竟然還被迫
要做智力與性向測驗
工作上做不好會被飆罵
博士是不是白讀的
這些都還算小事
可能是因為之前
曾經被背叛有了心理陰影
蕭克利嚴控資訊
常常不准員工
研究自己規定以外的事物
甚至會命令員工
去單獨的辦公室閉門工作
簡直像關禁閉
在大家到達臨界點
要爆了之前的那段時間
蕭克利還常因為懷疑員工
逼所有人測謊
事後眾人對他的評價都是
蕭克利無庸置疑
在研究上屬於天才
可惜卻不適合管人與管公司
蕭克利的經驗也讓「八叛徒」這群人
在自行創業時
深深考量過總經理的人選
蕭克利半導體實驗室
才在史丹佛研究園區落腳不到兩年
1957年八叛徒就帶著
從蕭克利身上學到的眾多半導體知識
離職並創了另一間新公司
快捷半導體（Fairchild Semiconductor）
快捷半導體很快步入軌道
尤其在商業化生產積體電路這塊
拔得頭籌
與當時的最大對手
德州儀器有來有回
就在此時
超越BJT
最最最重要的電晶體
終於被發明出來了
這個在蕭克利前東家
貝爾實驗室誕生的電晶體
與BJT截然不同
重要性卻超越BJT
成為現今生產數量最多
投入最多資源研究的電晶體
它就是
金屬氧化物半導體場效電晶體
MOSFET
這MOSFET是什麼呢
它其實與BJT長得很像
也是兩側是同型的半導體
中間通道則對應另一種半導體
例如n型就對應p型
但是控制開關的邏輯很簡單
透過基板上方的閘極施加電場
直接將電子塞入p型半導體
當p型轉為n型
那麼當所有人都是n型半導體
電子就能暢行無阻
這種透過外加電場
製作出載子通道的電晶體
就稱為「場效電晶體」
其實類似的概念蕭克利早就想到了
但卻遲遲未能做出成品
最主要的原因是p型半導體
在獲得電子後往往就變成空乏區
而不是n型通道
導致通過的電流微乎其微
貝爾實驗室這次最大的改良
就是在上方加了一層二氧化矽
這層二氧化矽
不但能隔絕電極的金屬
因為氧化物本身就是一個
價電子極其穩固的結構
不會平白無故吸收別人的電子
電場能穿透氧化層
在下方形成穩定的N型通道
當然這邊只是簡化後的介紹
實際上這牽涉到
金屬 絕緣體 半導體等不同材料間
量子力學中
電子的能階與能帶變化
這個我們以後有機會再說
MOSFET超越BJT
成為主流電晶體的最大原因
在於二氧化矽這層氧化物的出現
因為它是絕緣體
因此能阻擋電流流入
當我們施加電壓時
實際上只有電場進入了電晶體
並沒有電流穿過
因為控制閥沒有電流
功耗也能明顯降低
再者絕緣層的出現
代表我們多了一種方法
可以改良控制閥
讓電晶體的大小得以縮小
因為構造與功能與BJT不盡相同
因此三個電極的稱呼也不太一樣
用來控制的稱為閘極（gate）
輸入與輸出則是源極（source）
與汲極（drain）
MOSFET低功耗
適合快速開關的特性
非常適合用在處理器 記憶體
這些數位電路上
但是BJT
也並沒有就此被踢下擂台
而是轉換到屬於它自己的跑道
BJT在特定區段內
可以線性放大的特性
讓它在放大器等類比電路中
占有重要地位
這確實是MOSFET無法取代的
至此BJT MOSFET兩大電晶體之柱
都已經就位
半導體產業準備迎來飛快的成長
八叛徒也陸續從快捷半導體出走
各自設立新公司
在矽谷各地種下更多種子
你可以想像一塊晶片上
有超過１兆個電晶體嗎
台積電的最新技術
已經可以在晶片上
整合超過兩千億個電晶體了
2024年初
時任台積電董事長劉德音投書 IEEE
宣布為了應對AI的快速發展
要讓台積電有能力在10年內
透過3D系統整合技術
讓晶片上的電晶體數量成長5倍
也就是超過1兆個電晶體
要放在在單一晶片上
但你知道
電晶體一開始
只能隨便接在電路板上嗎
我們能讓晶片縮小再縮小
一切都要歸功於那個關鍵技術
「積體電路」的發明
當我們終於能將無數的電晶體
整合到單一材料上
晶片才得以微縮
摩爾定律才得以實踐
甚至「晶片」這個名詞
才因此誕生
今天我們就要來看看
積體電路誕生的故事
1947年
世界上第一顆電晶體
在貝爾實驗室中誕生
當時貝爾實驗室
開發電晶體的主要目的
是為了放大電話訊號
也就是用作為類比訊號放大器
而電晶體產業真正開始蓬勃發展
還得從蕭克利的八叛徒
正式背叛之後才開始
上一集我們提到
矽谷之祖蕭克利
雖然對電晶體的開發功不可沒
卻不是個好老闆
眾多無法被接受的行為
逼得手下的優秀人才紛紛出走
蕭克利不僅沒有反省
還稱這離開的八位員工為「八叛徒」
這邊也說一下八叛徒的結局
他們共同創立了
「快捷半導體」這間公司
雖然初期很美好
但隨著公司不斷成長
原先的八叛徒
與公司的營運方針
逐漸出現分歧
並陸續離開公司
直到1969年
八叛徒的最後一位成員
朱利亞斯布蘭克
也離開了快捷半導體
但八叛徒並沒有離開矽谷
而是各自創業
或擔任顧問與投資人
將半導體產業的種子
重新灑落在矽谷中
長成一顆又一顆的大樹
其中高登摩爾與羅伯特諾伊斯
創立了ＮＭ電子公司
後來改名 Intel 英特爾
尤金．克萊納（Eugene Kleiner）
創立了凱鵬華盈
成為全球頂尖的創投公司之一
傑里·桑德斯（Jerry Sanders）
和埃德溫·特尼（Edwin Turney）
成立超微半導體公司ＡＭＤ
唐·瓦倫丁則創立了紅杉資本
成為矽谷風險投資教父
這每一間公司都遐邇聞名
每一位都有很重要的影響力
但你也可以想想看
如果我們硬要從中選出一位
對半導體產業影響最深遠的人物
那會是誰呢
應該很多人會先選高登摩爾吧
因為他不僅是Intel的創辦人
更是摩爾定律的代言詞
這個答案沒有問題
但如果是站在
半導體科技發展的角度上來看
最具影響力的人物
肯定Intel的另一位共同創辦人
羅伯特·諾伊斯
我們得回到快捷公司
創立兩年後的1959年
雖然現在的我們
已經能在單一一個晶片上
放進上千億個電晶體
堪稱創舉
但在60年前
電晶體才剛被發明的時候
就像我們在實驗課接電路板一樣
電晶體 電阻 電容 二極體
要一個個焊接在電路板上
當所需的元件數量增加
電路板的體積
也就無可避免地跟著增加
並且電線錯綜複雜
就像個亂糟糟的城市發展
諾伊斯想要找到方法
解決這個問題
剛好
在快捷半導體公司內
八叛徒之一的
金·赫爾尼(Jean Hoerni)
在此時
提出一個電晶體結構的新專利
當時最先進的電晶體結構
被稱為檯面式結構
英文可能比較直白一點
稱為 Mesa Structure
Mesa 指的是平頂山
因為這種結構會一層一層向上建造
寬度最後也會逐漸縮減
最上方是一個平面
這就酷似美國西南部會出現的平頂山
因而得名
而檯面式結構其實上方也不是「平頂」
基極（base）和射極（emitter）
會從電晶體的上方凸出來
集極（collector）則在電晶體下方
這種結構有個很大的缺點
就是灰塵跟水滴
會輕易地沾染到電晶體上
尤其影響到PN接面的電特性
這邊我們回顧一下
P型半導體是在矽 鍺等半導體
摻雜三價元素所製成的
那N型半導體呢
則是摻雜五價元素製成的
也就是說
半導體是透過摻雜了雜質
來改變電特性
如果有灰塵或水氣等外來雜質進入
那就會嚴重影響到電晶體原本的效果
為此
赫爾尼重新設計了
另一種電晶體結構
原本在檯面式電晶體的製作過程中
會在表面上 蓋上一層氧化層
並進行雜質摻雜的步驟
最後再用溶劑
將氧化層溶解
全部清除乾淨
赫爾尼則認為
應該將氧化層保留下來
用來保護pn接面
在他的新設計中
二氧化矽會保護整個PN接面
只露出各極需要與外部導線
連接的接觸點
結果
這項改進
不僅增加電晶體的穩定性
更因為有了氧化層的隔絕
電極彼此在設計上可以更靠近
讓電晶體的運作效能提升
而且製造上也更為簡單
你看 而只是換個結構
就至少產生三個優點
讓快捷半導體的成員都非常興奮
也給了這種新結構
有別於檯面式結構的另一個名稱
平面式結構
但就在他們要申請專利的時候
諾伊斯的銳眼
又從中發現了更多可能性
他想
如果不只把電晶體改為平面化
而是把整個電路板
包含電阻 電容 二極體 導線
都放在同一個平面呢
諾伊斯心想
在電路板上
每一個元件真正發揮作用的元件體積
只佔了一小小部分
剩下的空間
不是被電線
電子元件的包裝外殼浪費
就是無意義的放在那邊
真正關鍵元件的體積
只佔了電路板的不到 5%
他參考赫爾尼的做法
將所有元件彼此緊鄰
原本的元件外殼
都改用氧化層作為隔絕
大幅減小每個元件的體積
並且聚集在同一個基板上
而元件與元件之間的線路
則用當時已經存在的
印刷電路板技術來完成
在基板上刻下凹槽
並印上金屬線的方法
可以讓整塊晶片上
完全沒有額外電線的出現
最後
這種在同一個平面上建立起的
「半導體器件連線結構」
就完成了
諾伊斯和快捷半導體的夥伴
都能看見這項發明的潛力與重大意義
但現實沒那麼順利
當他們終於申請專利時
律師卻告知他們
早在4個月之前
德州儀器的基爾比
就已經針對積體電路
先提出專利申請了
1958年5月
德州儀器新入職了一位工程師
傑克·基爾比(Jack Kilby)
他跟諾伊斯一樣
想要解決隨著電晶體
與電子元件數量增加
導致電路結構體積
過於複雜與龐大的問題
而他們的想法也很類似
就是要把所有元件
都融合在同一塊材料基板上
基爾比首先在同年8月做出了
以矽為原料的
電晶體 電阻與電容
證明這些元件
可以使用同一種材料完成
接著在9月
他就成功在同一片鍺上
完成了電路的整合
而且是一個確實有作用
可以生產正弦波的波形產生器
最後
他將這種在同一塊材料上
組合的電路取名為
「積體電路 integrated circuit」
基爾比從加入德州儀器
到發明積體電路只花了4個月
我想每個老闆
都會想要這種員工吧
題外話
在同一年來到德州儀器的
還有一個重要人物
他就是張忠謀
張忠謀在後來
把基爾比的重要發明形容為
一件驚天動地的大事
在我眼前默默發生
張忠謀從這時開始
也在德州儀器
推動了大大小小的半導體產業發展
而我們最熟悉的事蹟
則是要等到27年後的1985年
張忠謀來到台灣
先後擔任工研院院長
與台積電董事長兼CEO
為台灣帶來堅實的矽盾
這部分的故事
我們後面再來好好談談
回到積體電路
基爾比的設計呢
在1958年9月12日亮相
諾伊斯則是1959年1月提出設計
大約晚了四個月
但這邊也要說清楚
1969年法院判決
諾伊斯跟基爾比發明的積體電路
不存在侵權問題
兩邊的專利都有效
也就是在電晶體發展的潮流下
兩人都面臨電路
需要整合
縮小的問題
最後呢 用手段不同
但類似的方案來解決相同的問題
積體電路的發明
對後續的半導體發展影響重大
因為這代表
我們能將所有電路在同一片基板
例如矽或鍺上完成製造
再將積體電路
一片一片從基板上切下來
因為從大塊材料上
切一小塊下來的動作
英文稱為「chip off」
因此積體電路也獲得了
你我都熟知的別稱
chip 晶片
沒錯
我們的晶片
終於在1950年代末期誕生了
積體電路創造了晶片
也讓基爾比在公元2000年
獲得了諾貝爾物理學獎
然而可惜的是
當年基爾比已經77歲
諾伊斯則已經在10年前
就因為心臟病發離世
基爾比在獲獎致詞的時候
還特別提到
如果諾伊斯還活著的話
這份榮耀應該由我們兩位一起分享
事實上
諾伊斯也絕對值得獲得同樣的殊榮
因為基爾比的積體電路
雖然更早提出
但使用的電晶體
是尚未改良的檯面式結構
元件間的連結
也需要透過電線來連接
相對之下
諾伊斯的設計
同時包含了平面式結構
和用印刷電路板取代電線
這兩項重要概念
近代晶片的設計概念
基本上也是沿用
諾伊斯平面積體電路的概念
而且
我們必須把時間
再次推回到那個年代
因為諾伊斯在發明平面積體電路之後
故事還沒有結束
前面我們提到在蕭克利的八叛徒中
諾伊斯是最重要的一號人物
因為在快捷半導體
諾伊斯就像是八叛徒的領導者
帶領大家前進
而當快捷半導體逐漸成長
再次分崩離析
諾伊斯和高登摩爾
在1968年8月離開快捷半導體
決定一起創辦
對半導體產業影響深遠的英特爾
三年之後
他們做出了第一顆微處理器晶片
開啟了個人電腦時代
當半導體的需求逐年上升
矽谷在此時真正開始成長
諾伊斯對這個產業的貢獻
更讓他被稱為
the Mayor of Silicon Valley
意思是「矽谷市長」
三星和台積電
在先進製程的戰爭
看似台積電領先一個馬身
但就算三星哪天真的在邏輯晶片上
一敗塗地
三星在半導體市場中
仍然能夠坐擁半片江山
為什麼呢
因為電腦中的核心元件
除了CPU運算邏輯單元之外
還有一個重要性相等的元件
就是記憶體
而在記憶體的市場中
三星電子坐穩寶座
例如2023年
第四季度的DRAM全球市佔率
三星就佔了45.7%
是全球第一
縱觀歷史發展
DRAM
就像是另一頂半導體的王冠
不只扶起了三星
從Intel
到日本的SONY
日立
東芝的崛起
都脫離不了記憶體的影子
這頂王冠到底為什麼那麼重要
上集我們提到快捷半導體的諾伊斯
發明了積體電路
讓人類終於能創造出晶片
然而他的貢獻還不止於此
1968年8月
諾伊斯決定離開快捷半導體
創辦Intel
至今
Intel仍然是半導體產業中
最重要的企業之一
Intel的創辦人三巨頭
分別是高登摩爾
羅伯特諾伊斯
以及安迪葛洛夫
其中
摩爾跟諾伊斯
都是蕭克利八叛徒的成員
安迪格羅夫則是1963年
在高登摩爾的邀請下
才加入快捷半導體
並隨著摩爾一起創辦Intel
成為Intel的第三位員工
題外話
一開始他們創的公司名字
稍嫌隨便
稱為ＮＭ電子
各取諾伊斯跟摩爾的開頭英文字
至於為什麼不是反過來的
MN電子呢
那是因為
摩爾諾伊斯
聽起來就像是more noise
更多雜訊
這怎麼聽都不是適合電子公司的名字
Intel創立初期
馬上又推出兩個重要產品
1971年
Intel推出世界上第一顆
商用微處理器
intel 4004
也就是CPU
能夠處理4位元的資料
接着在1973年
法國公司R2E
推出第一款搭載CPU的電腦
Micral N
使用的CPU是intel 8008
在這之後
個人電腦的市場開始擴張
1977年 美國坦迪公司
推出第一款
大規模生產的桌上型家用電腦
TRS-80
1981年
IBM PC誕生
個人電腦PC這個詞開始普及
後來
更專指那些與IBM標準相容的電腦
對了
在這股熱潮開始發酵之前
有人早已經預測到
這股即將爆發的運算力
1965年
高登摩爾指出
積體電路上
可容納的電晶體數目
將成倍數增長
約每隔2年
便會增加一倍
這也就是著名的摩爾定律
然而 摩爾定律這個詞
不完全是摩爾本人創造的
概念是摩爾提出的沒錯
但用上摩爾定律
來稱呼這個現象的
是摩爾的好友
加州理工學院的卡佛米德所取的
還有
現在比較常聽到的
18個月翻倍
而不是2年
則是Intel的執行長
大衛豪斯所修正的
當摩爾定律向前推進
一臺電腦所需的體積
開始縮小
能做的工作
玩的遊戲
也開始增加
個人電腦市場的成長是必然
但除了更快的運算速度
還需要有更快更大的記憶體
來儲存資訊
輔助CPU計算時
讀寫 暫存資料
CPU 記憶體缺一不可
但在1960年代
記憶體竟然是一顆顆
運作緩慢的磁鐵
記憶體的任務其實很簡單
只要能負責記下0或1就好了
1970年代以前
這項任務
是交由一個個小磁鐵來完成的
這種記憶體被稱為磁芯記憶體
記憶體中
會串接一大堆密密麻麻的小圈圈
這些圈圈是鐵磁性材料
每一個圈圈都代表一個0
或是一個1
這些鐵磁性材料有一個特性
在沒有外加磁場時
總是會跟指南指北針一樣
不是指向南就是向北
有兩種磁化方向
重要的是
只要加上更大的外加磁場
就能覆寫掉原本的狀態
這樣磁化的方向逆轉
指北針變指南針
指南針變指北針
當時的人心想
只要把其中一種方向定義為0
另一種定義為1
就可以作為一個數位位元的記錄單元
而且還能用磁場來覆寫資訊
正好適合作為記憶體的材料
但要讀取磁性記憶體上面
現在儲存的是0還是1
其實並不簡單喔
我們必須施加一個與零同方向的
外加磁場
然後觀察位元是否因此產生變化
如果有發生磁極倒轉
位元從1變成0
我們就會在電路中
檢測到一個電脈衝
此時就能回推它
原本記錄的是1
如果外加磁場之後
什麼脈衝都沒檢測到
那我們這個位元是0
雖然我們辛苦得到資訊
但因為外加了一個磁場
因此最後所有的位元都變成0
是一種破壞式的讀取方式
而且讀取完之後
記得還要手動的
把位元再轉回到1
顯然
用一堆小磁鐵記錄位元
還需要大費周章
用外加磁場
進行讀取與寫入的方式
複雜且緩慢了
因為磁鐵不能靠得太近
記憶體晶片的體積也小不了
大家心想在計算上
電晶體取代了真空管
解決了速度跟體積的問題
那在記憶體上
是不是也能用電晶體
來取代緩慢且龐大的磁鐵呢
科學家們開始在既有的電路元件中
尋找更好的答案
最後他們看上的是
可以儲存電荷的電容
電容是由一組兩個靠得很近
但不互相接觸的金屬片所組成的
在這兩片金屬板上
可以儲存電荷
既然電容可以儲存電荷
也就等於可以儲存某種「狀態」
如果我們把電容
有儲存電的狀態視為1
沒儲存電的狀態視為0
是不是也是種能儲存0與1的元件呢
科學家基於這個想法做了一些調整
最後設計出了基於電荷
進行資訊儲存的記憶體
也就是我們聽過的DRAM
而且這個DRAM的構造
意外的非常非常簡單
就是一個電容
再加上一個電晶體
還記得電晶體的主要功能
就是一個開關嗎
通過開關的開關
可以決定橫向線路上的電流
是否能通過
所以在DRAM中
會透過字元線(Word Line, WL)
來控制電晶體開關
當開關打開時
位元線(Bit Line, BL)則可以判讀電容中
是有電還是沒有電
是1還是0
如果想要改寫電容儲存的資訊
也可以在開關打開時
對電容進行充電或放電
改變電容的狀態
就是這麼簡單
如果你想要一個
可以儲存很多資訊的記憶體晶片呢
那就把記憶體單元
串成一大個陣列就好了
難度也不高
因為記憶體用上了電晶體
自然也屬於高單價的科技產品
那Intel到底要選擇進攻CPU市場
還是記憶體市場呢
不用想也知道
那當然是我全都要啊
沒錯
Intel第二項
推動個人電腦快速發展的重要產品
就是記憶體
但我必須澄清一下
Intel雖然將生產DRAM
視為主要業務之一
但DRAM的最早發明人不是Intel
而是IBM的羅伯特丹納德
在1968年成功申請專利的
丹納德在半導體產業的貢獻
也非常巨大
甚至有以他名字命名的
丹納德縮放定律
Dennard scaling
指的是當電晶體越做越小
單位面積的晶片功率
仍會保持不變
功率的消耗與晶片的面積成正比
這項定律跟摩爾定律
並列為半導體三大定律之一
當時間開始往前推進
記憶體企業的版圖
也開始發生了變化
從矽谷向西望去
太平洋的另一端
一個巨大的對手
正開始崛起
1946年
一間叫做
東京通訊工業株式會社的公司
在日本成立了
12年後
改名為索尼株式會社
索尼1953年
就取得美國企業
AT&T的電晶體生產授權
開始進攻電晶體市場
並且很快就扶搖直上
這股熱潮也必須歸功於
二戰後美國對日本採取的態度
當時的美國認為
經濟發展
不僅可以防止日本
再次出現軍國主義
還能讓日本成為太平洋對岸
防堵共產主義的橋頭堡
在這之後
三菱電機
日立
富士通
東芝
日本電氣
都開始加入電晶體的競爭當中
這塊大餅也讓這些企業
成為至今耳熟能詳的名字
很快
日本用低價
高良率的產品
攻佔了全球的半導體市場
甚至在1980年代的高峰期
整個半導體產業的產值
曾一度佔全世界的一半
在DRAM市場中
日本企業甚至在1986年
達到市佔率80%
這段時間
都是日本公司自己在互相競爭
例如64 kb DRAM
由日立拿下市佔率冠軍
256 kb是日本電氣
1 mb則是東芝
美國大幅改變態度
認為這是一場經濟戰爭
1986年
美國認定日本DRAM傾銷
並制定美日半導體協議
這協議要求日本開放市場
制定記憶體價格的下限
甚至對共3億美元的日本消費品
徵收100%的懲罰性關稅
再加上1986同年
日本經濟泡沫破裂
迎來失落30年
日本半導體產業開始走下神壇
最後接棒日本記憶體版圖的
是韓國
韓國三星
在國家力量的強力扶植下
迅速攻佔記憶體市場
1992年
三星超過日本電氣
成為世界第一的DRAM製造商
並在隔年達成全球DRAM市佔率50%
再隔年
三星已經搶先全球
推出當代最先進的
256 mb DRAM
從此
三星在DRAM領域走上神壇
至今無人能敵
但等等
事情可能沒有那麼簡單
就像電晶體
即將從FinFET
走向GAAFET的時代
沒人知道未來10年
電晶體的市場會不會突然大洗牌
寶座換人坐
記憶體的賽局也一樣
各大企業
已經投入下一世代的新型記憶體開發
這些記憶體不僅挑戰小的極限
還可以在維持
與DRAM讀寫速度相同的情況下
具備不怕斷電的特性
即使沒有電源供應還能維持記憶
讓你電腦開關機
只要一瞬間
台積電在次世代記憶體有重大突破
難道三星連記憶體的龍頭寶座
都要被台積電撼動了嗎
2024年初
工研院宣佈和台積電
聯手打造出全世界最快的磁性記憶體
SOT-MRAM
有望在AI 次世代記憶體的市場中
取得先機
這新型記憶體不只讀取速度極快
耗電極低
在運算伺服器一臺比一臺大的未來
只會越來越重要
更厲害的是這種記憶體
甚至不怕斷電
斷電也不會失憶
集所有優點在一身
它是怎麼做到的呢
除了MRAM之外
還有哪些新型記憶體
會成為各家大廠的王牌
角逐這個記憶體市場呢
上一集我們提到
要快速的儲存跟讀寫資訊
比起笨重的磁鐵
更好的選擇是電容
一個電晶體加上一顆電容
就是最簡單的記憶單元
電容有或沒有電
就代表數位位元中的1與0
當需要讀取資料
或是改寫資料的時候
只需要將電晶體的開關打開
就能對電容進行讀或寫
不過現實沒有那麼理想
因為就算電晶體關上了
其實還是會緩緩的產生漏電流
所以這種設計
需要不斷的幫電容重新充電
來重溫記憶
不過總不能取名為漏電記憶體吧
所以被稱為「動態」隨機存取記憶體
英文就是 Dynamic RAM
縮寫 DRAM
還有因為只要
長時間斷電
電容的電就會全部放光光
這暫時儲存的記憶
消失殆盡
因此這些記憶體
又被稱為揮發性記憶體
如果這資料想要長期儲存的話
千萬不能放在這
而必須放在硬碟或是隨身碟這類
「非揮發性」的快閃記憶體裡
揮發跟非揮發性記憶體
各有缺點
例如揮發性記憶體中的DRAM
需要頻繁充電
這個頻率現實中大約是每64毫秒一次
一秒15.6次
這在電腦需要增加記憶體時
尤其是現在AI模型
AI PC
AI phone
不斷進化的現在
這一臺臺電腦
將逐漸膨脹成吃電怪獸
而非揮發性記憶體
也有它的問題
雖然其中的快閃記憶體
不會因為斷電而失憶
但是在不斷寫入並消去記憶的過程中
高電壓會漸漸破壞結構中的氧化層
因此一個快閃記憶體的寫入次數
是有限制的
有著壽命短的缺點
除此之外 最大的硬傷是
讀寫速度比起DRAM慢很多
也就是說
面對次世代的記憶體市場
目標其實很明確
那就是我們能否開發出一款
有着綜合優點的記憶體
它既快速
壽命長
同時還省電
且不怕斷電
為了開發出全新型態的記憶體
科學家開始研究不同的材料與結構
其中之一就是磁阻式記憶體
MRAM
這顧名思義
就是要用磁力來儲存資訊
哎等等
我們上集不是才說
磁力是1970年代
就被淘汰掉的選項嗎
哎 是沒錯
但先前的磁鐵既大且笨重
而這次使用的磁鐵
可比1970年代的小得多
我們必須先看向更源頭
那就是磁鐵的磁力
到底是怎麼產生的
背後的原理相當複雜
我們直接以一個
最簡化的版本來說好了
可以先想像
磁鐵裡頭
是由更多許多微小的小磁鐵所組成的
這個小磁鐵就是材料中的電子
為什麼電子也會有磁性呢
在量子力學中
每顆電子雖然肉眼看不出來在旋轉
但是都帶有叫做自旋的量子特性
這個自旋又會產生磁性
並且磁力方向會指向某個特定方向
就像是一個小小的指北針
OK 要瞭解MRAM是如何運作的
我們只要瞭解到這就好
也就是磁性是與電子自旋有關係
而且自旋的方向
與磁化的方向有關係
重點來了
當某一顆電子
想要通過某塊磁性材料
如果它的自旋方向
和材料的磁化方向一樣
那它就像能輕易融入自己的同溫層一樣
可以順利通過
相反的
如果電子想要穿過一群
自旋方向和它相反的同夥
就會受到很多阻礙
也就是遭遇比較大的電阻
這稱為巨磁阻效應
雖然人類在公元前
就已經有使用磁鐵的記錄
但這個巨磁阻效應
是直到1988年才被發現
並在2007年獲得諾貝爾物理學獎
那要怎麼運用這個巨磁阻效應
來設計記憶體呢
就像電容用有電跟沒電
兩種狀態來儲存1與0
巨磁阻效應
也能用低電阻與高電阻兩種狀態
來代表1與0
在MRAM中
會用兩塊磁性材料
夾住一片非磁性材料
這樣做的目的
是為了分別控制
左右兩塊材料的磁化方向
電路中的電子自旋方向不固定
有朝上也有朝下的
但當兩塊材料
磁化方向同樣向上
自旋向上的電子
自旋向上的電子就可以輕鬆通過第一塊
與第二塊
整體電阻較小
可是如果兩塊材料的磁化方向
相反
那麼不論是向上
還是向下
電子都很難同時通過兩塊材料
這時候整體的電阻值就會變大
實際在記憶體的架構中
通常會做成一個雙鐵磁層的結構
固定其中一層的磁化方向
例如朝右
然後再將位元寫入第二層
如果要記錄1 就將磁化方向向右
如果是0
就將磁化方向向左
這個磁化方向會被保留下來
之後讀取的時候
只要由上往下通電
測量電阻的大小
就可以知道這兩層的磁化方向
是相同還是相反
藉此得到1與0的結果
以上就是磁阻式記憶體的運作原理
磁阻式的優點是
磁性可以長時間儲存
因此屬於非揮發式記憶體
而與上集提到
1960年代使用的磁芯記憶體相比
元件體積小
讀取寫入又十分方便
幾乎媲美DRAM
當然MRAM也有它的發展瓶頸
那就是如何精準的控制
小小一層鐵磁層的磁化方向
而不會影響到其它位元
最早期的方法就是在鐵磁層附近
放一條導線
利用導線通電時產生的電磁場
去改變極化的方向
可是要避免導線產生的磁場
影響到四面八方的位元
每個記憶單元單元彼此之間
都得間隔一段距離
對於尺寸微縮的限制相當大
MRAM因此一直難以登上擂臺
一直要到公元2000年左右
科學家才做出讓MRAM
谷底翻身的重要發現
如果先讓電流
通過某個極化向上的鐵磁層
讓電子被篩選
剩下大部分都是自旋向上的電子
再拿這個電流
通過第二層未極化的鐵磁層
竟然會對第二層材料中的電子
施加力矩
強制他們轉向為相同的自旋方向
這就像是一群跳特定舞步的人
進入舞池
改變了整個舞池的舞步方向
自旋極化的電子
也會改變磁性材料的磁化方向
而不需要外加磁場
這個現象稱為
「自旋轉移力矩」（Spin-transfer torque）
簡稱為STT
跟剛才提到使用外部導線製造磁場
來改變磁化方向的方法相比
STT不用外加磁場
而是單純透過通電流
就能改變鐵磁層的極化方向
達成寫入位元的效果
而因為不會影響到旁邊的位元
因此解決了
位元彼此不能太靠近的問題
這種使用STT技術的產品
就叫做STT-MRAM
因為符合當代運算的尺寸需求
在2016年
由 Everspin 商業化量產
要瞭解這個領域的最新進展
當然還是要請教專家
今天我們很高興邀請到
臺大電機工程學系的胡璧合教授
來跟我們分享次世代記憶體的最新進展
那胡璧合教授我們想要瞭解
我們看到的是工研院跟台積電
在2024年發表了
一個叫做SOT-MRAM的新產品
這跟我們之前提到
前幾年比較熱門的STT-MRAM
有什麼差別
所謂的SOT指的是自旋軌道力矩
Spin Orbit Torque
它的寫入操作模式跟STT有所不同
利用的是自旋霍爾效應
SOT-MRAM的寫入模式
並不是利用自旋極化的電流
流經磁性材料層
而是讓這個電流
從旁邊流過
那透過分開寫入跟讀取的
電流路徑
來達到讓這個記憶體有更好的
更大的操作的次數
也可以更減少這個功率的消耗
那除了台積電提出的這個SOT-MRAM
其實我們還聽到很多不同種類的記憶體
老師可以跟我們介紹一下
它彼此之間的差異
除了SOT-MRAM之外
其實還有其他三種
至少三種以上的主流的新興記憶體
首先我介紹第一種叫做電阻式的記憶體
RRAM
那電阻式記憶體
它都是透過兩層金屬層
中間夾着一個過渡金屬氧化物
形成一個三明治的結構
那麼透過施加不同的電壓
來改變過渡金屬氧化物的電阻值
達到0跟1的狀態
這個是第一個電阻式的記憶體
那第二種叫做相變化記憶體
相變化記憶體
它的結構也很像三明治的結構
但中間的材料
用的是硫化的
硫屬化物的這個玻璃的材料
那麼透過加熱
可以改變這個硫屬化物這一層
它的晶相
可以讓它是一個多晶的狀態
也可以是一個非晶的狀態
透過改變它的晶相
來達到這個不同的電阻值
來形成0跟1的狀態
那第三種記憶體
是鐵電記憶體
鐵電記憶體其實是一個蠻古老的記憶體
傳統上我們使用的是鈣鈦礦的材料
作為鐵電層的材料
但在2011年的時候
科學家發現有一種
已經大量在使用的
高介電系數的半導體材料
叫做二氧化鉿
它已經可以在45奈米的技術節點時候
被引入來縮小
電晶體的閘極氧化層的有效厚度
2011年科學家發現
它除了高介電係數之外還有鐵電特性
這件事情大家就非常感興趣
因為一個已經在大量使用的材料
代表了它對整個產線
完全沒有污染
所以接受度很高
所以近年來有非常多的研究
在如火如荼的進行當中
那鐵電記憶體的操作
最主要是利用鐵電層
它裡面的電偶極的翻轉
透過翻轉電偶極正電負電的方向
來達到讓下方電晶體的電流
能比較容易通過
比較不容易通過
達到高低電流的狀態
藉此來形成0跟1兩種特性
那老師您認為這些次世代記憶體
會讓整個記憶體的市場大洗牌嗎
能不能讓整個記憶體市場大洗牌
我覺得這個方向可能不完全是
大家可以接受的方向
但是我們要思考是這些新興記憶體
能不能用來彌補
現有的記憶體階層架構的空缺
我們現有的記憶體階層的架構
我們剛才在前面可能沒有提到
一個商業化記憶體
我們速度最快會是SRAM
它是一個快取記憶體
再來是主記憶體DRAM
他們的操作速度都是奈秒等級
速度非常快
但是因為SRAM它本身所需要的最基本的
記憶體單元至少要六個電晶體
所以它的面積很大
面積大代表就是高成本
所以它沒有辦法像其他記憶體
可以做到很大的這個容量
很大的capacity
除了SRAM跟DRAM操作速度很快之外
大家常在使用的USB
或是你的固態硬碟
利用的技術
我們叫做FlashMemory
它叫快閃記憶體
快閃記憶體它的優勢就是成本低
然後可以做到很高的容量
大家的硬碟都至少有
1TB到2TB以上
但是它操作速度慢很多
大概是micro-second等級
所以你可以想像
nano-second跟micro-second等級
在這個系統當中
其實中間有一個很大的速度的差距
新興記憶體最大潛力就是
希望來補足這一塊速度的差距
同時新興記憶體還有一個很棒的優點
就是它一樣是一個
跟這個快閃記憶體一樣
是一個非揮發性的記憶體
所謂非揮發性記憶體就是
當你把電源關掉的時候
裡面的資料還存在
所以同學們存的作業 照片
就是存在這種非揮發性記憶體裡面
那揮發性記憶體
就是我們剛剛提到速度較快的
SRAM跟DRAM
它只有在我們把電腦打開
電源打開的時候
它才可以透過讀取存在其他地方的資訊
透過這個暫存的方式來儲存
但它沒有辦法存你的作業
或是存你的照片
像這樣的差距
新興記憶體它有相對快的速度
接近奈秒等級的操作
同時又是非揮發性
所以希望來彌補
目前的記憶體階層的空缺
讓整個系統呢可以是一個
有更好的性能以及更低的成本
所以我不會說新興記憶體
會讓整個這個記憶體產業大洗牌
但我們應該思考是這些新興記憶體
能不能去彌補目前所達不到的事情
讓整體的系統性能
可以變得更好
新興記憶體還是非常有潛力
甚至我們這個單元最主要提的MRAM
過去有人希望它是一個
universal memory
MRAM它本身也是奈秒等級的操作速度
所以它有機會來取代我們
快取記憶體最慢的這個階層
我們叫 last cache memory 這個階層
同時具有非揮發性的特性
所以你就可以降低功率消耗
因為你不需要把data再recall
再恢復一次
它同時因為具備非揮發性的特性
而且有比較好的讀寫次數
它的讀寫次數可以比較高
這就有機會來取代我們目前
作為儲存裝置使用的快閃記憶體
所以這些新興記憶體
在對應不同的應用上面有
很多的潛力
但如果我們要來提說
記憶體的要求是什麼
或是說到底誰能勝出
目前真正的這個
世界是這樣的
我們沒有辦法只依賴單純的一種記憶體
我們需要整合各種記憶體它的優點
來因應不同的應用
我先舉例來說
像我們使用的手機
或是高能耗 高效能的伺服器
它其實就是相對的
我們說電力需求其實是非常高的
那我們在記憶體的應用上面
我們可能就需要發展比較高速的記憶體
但是它可能功率消耗能量比較高
為了滿足我們現在的伺服器的需求
我們還是需要用這樣子的高速記憶體
但如果是一些常見的像是穿戴裝置
它可能需要相當低的耗能
那它的操作速度不需要那麼快
不需要有那麼大的要求
所以這個記憶體設計
需要是一個比較
是一個低功耗的設計
然後比較reliable
不需要常常去對它充電
這個是我們的需求
所以因應不同的需求
記憶體會有這些不同的方向
感謝老師的說明
隨著 AI 3C 市場的蓬勃發展
不論是邏輯晶片
還是記憶體的半導體市場
競爭只會越來越激烈
誰能掌握新設計
誰就能掌握先機
而掌握整片市場
而在這場競爭中
除了晶片結構技術上的競爭
還有另一個領域的競爭不能忽視
就是製作這些晶片的設備
例如
當中國無法取得艾斯摩爾的
EUV極紫外光曝光機時
竟然會影響到整個國家的
半導體產業發展
現在的電晶體
可以做的越來越小
很大原因都必須歸功於
這個人
前兩集我們提到
Intel與一眾日本公司
將CPU和DRAM發揚光大
開闢了個人電腦市場
全面開啟晶片時代
但隨著大家繼續追求
更高的積體電路效能
要如何做出更小的積體電路
卻困擾著所有科學家
似乎一下子
就撞上電晶體的發展極限
就在這時候
德州儀器的一位工程師
提出創新的方法
開創了半導體產業最關鍵的
「微影製程」技術
然後透過微影製程
追逐摩爾定律的賽道
就此開放
直到今天
一道極紫外光微影製程
EUVL
就足以讓生產EUV機台的ASML
佔據半導產業中的關鍵地位
而一道針對 EUV 的禁售令
就足以撼動
整個中國的半導體產業
到底微影製程是什麼
它為什麼是半導體產業的關鍵
就讓我們來看看
那個工程師的故事
他就是傑伊．萊斯羅普
在第六集我們提到
德州儀器的工程師
傑克·基爾比(Jack Kilby  )
在1958年進入德州儀器後
只花了四個月就做出積體電路
與快捷半導體的諾伊斯
一同被認為是積體電路的發明者
可以說沒有他們
就沒有現在的「晶片」
對德州儀器來說
有個更好的消息
同一年將有一位新同事加入
帶來關鍵的「微影製程」技術
幫助德州儀器
在量產積體電路的能力上
快速成長
我們稍微把時間往回轉一點
來到一年前這位關鍵人物
還沒加入德州儀器的時候
當時是1957年
傑伊．萊斯羅普（Jay Lathrop）
還在美國陸軍的戴蒙德實驗室工作
這個實驗室負責開發
近炸引信（Proximity fuze）
也就是要讓迫擊砲
可以在目標上方的特定高度引爆
提高殺傷效果
他們想要設計一種包含電容的裝置
可以讓砲彈在下落過程中
根據大氣與地面的靜電感應
累積電荷
最後觸發雷管引發爆炸
當時還被廣泛使用的笨重真空管
顯然不適合直接塞進砲彈中
他們理所當然的
看上了當時正快速發展的電晶體
希望用電晶體取代真空管
還記得吧
之前我們說過諾伊斯提出的
平面電晶體結構
甚至比基爾比的還要晚
1959年才提出專利申請
所以此時的電晶體
顯然都還是檯面式結構
這些電晶體通常由鍺製成
並一層一層的
將摻雜不同雜質的半導體向上疊
當然
不是把材料隨便疊在一起就好了
就像疊積木
每一塊都有特定的形狀
電晶體的每一層
也都需要再加工
為了雕刻出正確的形狀
當時的作法是用蠟保護材料
露出想要進行雕刻的部分
再進行化學蝕刻
這個方法
是蕭克利半導體實驗室中的
哈利·塞洛(Harry Sello)所想到的
會選用蠟的原因是
用來蝕刻的氧化性酸液
雖然會腐蝕矽和鍺
但蠟卻可以抵抗這些酸液
因此當酸液被注入
那些沒蠟保護的地方
就會逐漸被腐蝕
蝕刻出我們想要的形狀
有蠟保護的地方則完好如初
這有點像是我們小時候玩沙畫的時候
整個沙畫板上都有貼紙的保護
只有被撕開
露出膠的部分
才可以被有顏色的沙加工
塞洛的這種作法稱為
wax masking
中文的意思是「蠟遮罩」
它確實是一個簡單有用的辦法
但當電晶體的體積與設計
逐漸縮小
就開始遇到問題
大家發現
蠟很難畫出精準且細小的圖案
尤其蠟的流動性
會導致圖案邊緣出現誤差
圖案越小這個誤差就越明顯
戴蒙德實驗室的
傑伊．萊斯羅普和吉姆·納爾
在近炸引信的開發上也因此卡關
那該怎麼解決這個問題呢
出人意料的是
最後他們找到的解決方案
竟然是來自一間
專門做膠片的公司
柯達
在感光元件CCD和數位相機
還沒被發明以前
使用底片還是拍照的主要方法
底片上會塗上含有「鹵化銀晶體」的乳劑
鹵化銀包含溴化銀 碘化銀
和氯化銀等化合物
都是對光非常敏感的化學成分
拍照時相機的快門會快速開闔
讓底片接受到極短時間的曝光
進入鏡頭的光線
會讓銀離子產生還原反應
從銀離子變成不透光的銀原子
但是這個階段的銀原子還小的看不見
因此稱為『潛影』
在隨後的底片沖洗過程中
銀原子會在顯影劑的作用下
催化旁邊更多的銀離子
還原為金屬銀
並進一步加深乳劑的變黑程度
形成肉眼可見的黑色影像
那些未受光沒有形成潛影的的區域
則繼續保持透明
最後定影液會溶解
這些透明
沒有參與反應的鹵化銀
底片上面便留下負片的圖案
在這之後
還有負片反轉沖洗的步驟
我們就不再深談
這裡的關鍵是
為了做出更好的照片
例如解析度更高
或是超越黑白
能拍出彩色的照片
柯達投入許多感光材料的開發
對象不限鹵化銀
而被萊斯羅普看上
可以用在電晶體製作的
是一種稱為「光阻劑」的產品
光阻劑在受到紫外光等光線照射後
也會產生化學變化
但重點不是變黑
而是溶解度會產生改變
光線照到的地方會變硬
沒有被光線照到的地方則還是原樣
可以被顯影液沖洗掉
留下我們要的圖案
那麼要怎麼控制光線
照射在哪些地方的光阻劑上呢
他們在每天使用的顯微鏡中找到靈感
顯微鏡的作用是
把物體反射的光線透過透鏡放大
那如果把整台顯微鏡反轉
是不是就能經由透鏡
把光線集中
縮小在很小的區域呢
這樣只要把阻擋光線的遮罩
放在顯微鏡上
再照射光線
就能把相同圖案的縮小版本
照射在小小的光阻劑上
這個遮罩mask
因為可以控制光線的進入
現在則通常被稱為「光罩」
簡單來說
這套方法就是把用來保護材料的蠟
換成光阻劑
而刻畫光阻劑的方法
則是利用光罩
與反轉的顯微鏡鏡片組
對光阻劑進行「曝光」
並利用光阻劑自身的特性
來達成如同雕刻的效果
萊思羅普將這種用光印刷的方法
命名為微影製程(photolithography)
分別是照片photo
跟石版印刷lithography
兩個字的融合
微影製程技術
很快就在半導體產業大放異彩
這種方法不僅改良了
電晶體製造時的精度問題
光罩的出現更實現了
電晶體的高品質
工業化量產
更重要的是微影製程
為未來的晶片微縮
展示了該努力的方向
1957年
萊思羅普和納爾申請了專利
並且被美國陸軍公開表揚
獲得了兩萬五千美元的獎金
但現在的我們知道
這項發明的價值
絕對不只值兩萬五千元美金
而當時的德州儀器
快捷半導體
和許多公司一樣
也意識到了這點
一場微影製程的競爭就此打響
萊思羅普和快捷半導體的諾伊斯
本來是在麻省理工學院
攻讀物理博士學位的同學
畢業後仍持續保持聯絡
當諾伊斯得知萊思羅普
加入德州儀器後
他馬上做出決斷
將萊思羅普的同事搭檔
納爾給挖角了過來
至此德州儀器和快捷半導體
都開始發展微影製程技術
除了向柯達購買光阻劑外
也各自在光罩的開發上努力
而除了微影製程
兩間公司又分別在
基爾比和諾伊斯的帶領下
成功開發出積體電路
這部分
就是我們先前介紹過的故事了
時間往前推進
電晶體的尺寸開始從數公分
縮小到數毫米甚至數微米
微影製程的重要
只有增加沒有減少
最擅長製作微影製程設備的
也不再是德州儀器
這些半導體研發公司
而是那些更擅長精密光學的公司
例如在1970年代
稱霸整個微影製程設備的
是一間至今仍存在
總部位於美國
叫做珀金埃爾默的公司
他們本來就擅長生產
軍事用的光學瞄準鏡
以及衛星與偵查使用的鏡頭
因為他們能完美的將光線對準圖案
因此很快稱霸了微影製程
但到了1980年
寶座換了人坐
在當時
人還在德州儀器的張忠謀建議下
一間叫做GCA的公司
推出了世界上第一台
步進曝光機(stepper)
這種曝光機可以在晶圓上
一格一格地移動
印出一塊一塊
圖案相同的晶片
但很快GCA又因為公司
經營策略上的錯誤
過度擴張而瀕臨破產
最後
原本負責提供GCA透鏡的Nikon
決定走自己的路
他們逆向拆解GCA的步進機
並做出了他們自己的步進機
GCA的營運失敗
再加上Nikon做的步進機
品質真的好太多了
故障率非常低
最後Nikon在市場上打敗了GCA
日本企業Nikon和Canon
成為微影製程設備市場上的
主要競爭者
十年河東 十年河西
從德州儀器
珀金埃爾默
GCA
到1980年代的Nikon和Canon
領導微影製程設備的公司
不斷更迭
10年後的1990年代
另一頭巨獅也逐漸露出獠牙
準備角逐這個
重要的微影製程市場
這頭巨獅就是來自荷蘭的設備商
ASML
ASML的登場
與EUV的機台開發
將徹底改變
微影製程市場的遊戲規則
你我現在也常看到在新聞中看到
台積電憑什麼成為
全世界最重要的企業之一
這小小一塊晶片
就為台積電創下2.16 兆元的營收
佔了台灣2023年
國民生產毛額近十分之一
2024年7月台積電的市值更突破一兆
是僅次於輝達
市值最高的半導體企業
半導體產業已經不只是企業間的競爭
更能撼動一個國家的經濟與國防
這場現代科技
乃至政治經濟中最激烈的博弈
也稱為「晶片戰爭」
為什麼台積電這麼重要
還有為什麼是台灣創造了台積電呢
我們得換個視角
由這顆小小的電晶體來回答
為什麼第三次工業革命
竟然由奈米級的它來開啟
還記得半導體產業是怎麼崛起的嗎
1959年諾伊斯發明平面式積體電路
兩年前的1957年
萊斯羅普發展微影製程技術
這兩項發明
分別代表「晶片Chip」的誕生
以及工業化量產晶片的方法被確立
晶片時代正式開啟
10年後的1968年
諾伊斯和摩爾離開快捷半導體
創立Intel開始經營記憶體晶片
和邏輯晶片
還有個人電腦的生意
讓半導體的市場和產業快速發展
但就在1968年
也發生了一件對台灣來說很重要的事
當年德州儀器為了確認
台灣是否適合設廠
派了兩位重量級人物來台考察
並與當時擔任經濟部長的李國鼎見面
這兩位人物
一位是隔年成為德州儀器執行長的雪普德
另一位就是張忠謀
在這次會面之後
李國鼎花了17年的時間軟磨硬泡
才說服張忠謀來台灣
事後證明這個超長的徵才任務
非常有價值
也可以說李國鼎非常有眼光
知道電晶體與半導體產業
是非投資不可的項目
但說到底為什麼電晶體如此重要
而且半導體的產能需求
一年比一年高呢
在 AI 時代
我們都知道唯有追求更強大的電腦
運算更強大的模型
用更短的時間
進行辨識 演算 生成
才能打敗市場上其他對手
聽起來很複雜
但也可以講得很簡單
因為只需要0和1這兩個數字
就能用數位資訊
來進行所有的資訊儲存與運算
但如果只是要表達0跟1
我們用電燈也能辦到
我們可以讓燈泡在通電發亮時代表1
在不通電時代表0
那麼一連串發亮或不發亮的燈泡
也可以組成一整串的資訊
例如摩斯密碼
電腦當然不只是能開關的電燈
它之所以能跑AI模型
進行各種各樣的運算
就在於它懂得「思考」
也就是「邏輯運算」
要電腦思考
不是說讓它獲得跟人類
或智慧生物一樣的生物大腦
實際上就算是GPT
這種超大型生成式語言模型
追根究柢
背後還是一台超級電腦在運算它
而構成這台超級電腦的
是一個一個小處理器
而處理器中最小的單元
就是一顆一顆小小的邏輯閘
邏輯閘是什麼呢
它就像是一個可以設定規則的小機器
如果我們將剛才的燈泡開關
從一個變兩個
中間再接上一顆「邏輯閘」
就可以玩出許多花樣
例如我們可以設計「AND」閘
給這組裝置加上限制
只有當兩個開關都打開時燈泡才會亮
如果換成「OR」閘
則只要任一個開關打開燈泡就會亮
如果喜歡搞特別一點的
那就來個「XOR」閘
只有當開關一開一關時燈泡才會亮
複習一下
這種邏輯閘並不是電晶體才能做到的事
我們介紹過在還沒有電晶體的1937年
天才數學家克勞德·夏農
就用繼電器做出
能完成複雜邏輯運算的開關電路
邏輯閘雖然看似只能做簡單的分類工作
但這些小元件已經從單純的開關
變成了可以做基本邏輯運算的核心
例如我只要重新排列組合一下
組合一個AND和一個XOR
就能做出一個最簡單的半加法器
可以計算0+0等於0
1+0等於1
0+1等於1
你說這誰都會
這種電腦有誰需要
先別急 再更進一步
拿組好的兩個半加法器
再加上4個AND排列組合
就可以做出這個可以計算
從0乘0到3乘3的二進位乘法器
很快的我們從邏輯判斷進化到了加法
再進化到了乘法
以此類推
只要拿夠多的邏輯閘來做排列組合
我們就可以計算除法 開根號 微積分
到各種數學計算
再更進一步
這些數學運算單元組成的電腦
就能完成你想得到的任何工作
當然這裏面還有許多眉角被省略了
最明顯的問題
就是我們不可能為每一個數學公式
都重新設計一個電路
例如計算平方的電路
計算立方的電路
那麼如何設計出一台電腦
可以勝任所有的工作呢
這跟我們之前提到的馮諾伊曼架構
或是哈佛架構有關
我們在這邊不細談
如果你想要了解這些細節
請到泛科學留言讓我們知道
回到我們的問題
我們知道有邏輯閘就能做到任何事
但是為什麼這些機關
能夠做出邏輯判斷呢
難道是有個小小外星人作業員
住在裡面嗎
原來邏輯閘的內部就是電晶體
電晶體的原理我們先前也介紹過了
它與前輩真空管都被稱為「三極體」
特色是可以像一個小水閥一樣
用小電流控制大電流可以通過還是關閉
如果忘記了 沒有關係
待會這集看完再去複習一下
總結來說電晶體就像是一個小水閥
只要沒有輸入電壓就會關閉
有輸入電壓就會打開
如果串接兩個電晶體呢
你就會發現
只有當兩個水閥都同時打開了
才會有水流流出去
這就是一個AND閘
當然其他邏輯閘就不見得那麼簡單了
例如XOR閘長這樣
以此類推
電晶體可以組成所有的邏輯閘
而邏輯閘能完成所有的計算
因此電晶體就是邏輯晶片CPU的核心
現在的我們
不論是要打造運算更快的CPU
或是能同時平行運算
多項任務的多核心CPU
避不開的就是生產更多電晶體
或是開發更新 更小的晶片結構
事實上從Intel創立開始
全世界對運算力的需求就有增無減
直到現在這場追逐算力的競賽
也還沒看到終點
當第三次工業革命的浪潮席捲全世界
成功乘在浪尖上的台積電
也將台灣推向國際
可為什麼台積電會在台灣
而不是其他地方呢
從護國神山台積電
乃至台灣整個半導體產業
所構成的「矽盾」
台灣有三位重要人物你一定要知道
這三位分別是孫運璿
李國鼎和張忠謀
孫運璿和李國鼎
在1960年代先後擔任經濟部長
被認為是台灣經濟與科技業的重要推手
其中孫運璿1946年成為台電首任處長
積極推動台灣的電網重建
為經濟打下深厚基礎
並且在1973年建立「工業技術硏究院」
還有 在1970年代
台灣推動十大建設的同時
他與李國鼎還有清大的前校長徐賢修
共同促成「新竹科學工業園區」的建立
這每項事蹟都對台灣的經濟影響深遠
談到建立工研院與竹科
也得算上李國鼎一份
但李國鼎還有另一項重要的功績
那就是把張忠謀拉來台灣
長達17年的招募行動
讓張忠謀印象深刻
2023年11月李國鼎基金會
頒發第一屆李國鼎獎
得獎人呢 就是張忠謀
張忠謀致詞時說到
沒有李國鼎就沒有台積電
根據張忠謀的回憶
他與李國鼎之間有三幕交手
第一幕就是1968年的初次會面之後
到1980之間
李國鼎幾乎每年都飛到
張忠謀任職的德州儀器去參觀
又接連邀請他來台灣
參觀正在建設中的竹科
希望能夠說服張忠謀來台灣
第二幕是德州儀器董事長 Haggerty
1980年過世後
1982年李國鼎再次邀請他
來台灣擔任工研院院長
張忠謀再三考量後還是拒絕了
他還記得李國鼎回信中看的到憤怒
信裡說
給你那麼好的offer都不來
最後一幕是終於說動張忠謀
在1985年來台擔任工研院院長
最後在擔任院長三星期後
李國鼎找他成立半導體公司台積電
還說服政府投資台積電
張忠謀補充
台積電的商業模式還有怎麼建立
這些是我的主意
但是推動
說服政府投資一半
這個是李國鼎做的
這裡張忠謀提到的商業模式
指的就是晶圓代工
張忠謀預測
無廠半導體公司會大量出現
也就是半導體產業分工會走向細緻化
會出現單純做晶片設計的公司
相對的晶圓代工也將成為廣大的市場
張忠謀讓台積電只製造 不設計
與其他企業保持「合作」
而非競爭的關係
這個策略是個伏筆
在下一集我們談
台積電與三星大戰的時候
這個策略造成的後果就會開始發酵
時間快進到公元2000年以後
亞洲的半導體製造商
基本上就是
台積電跟三星兩大巨頭正在競爭
但三星可不是簡單的對手
蘋果從 iPhone 的第一代晶片開始
選擇的就都是三星而非台積電
而在現實層面隨著電晶體繼續縮小
到了約20奈米左右的節點
我們發現電晶體已經無法再縮小了
如果再縮小電晶體就會漏電
耗電增加
邏輯閘變得失效
面對這個問題
台積電會出什麼招呢
又有誰能來延續摩爾定律呢
半導體台韓大戰
最後笑的是誰呢
自台積電成立以來
最大的商業競爭對手
一直都是同屬於晶片製造公司的
南韓三星
1984年
三星開始幫英特爾生產64Kb DRAM
1987年
三星就能自行生產
領先世界水準的
4Mb DRAM
而這一年 台積電才剛創立
甚至蘋果從iPhone的第一代晶片開始
就全部交由三星生產
即使雙方在智慧型手機上激烈競爭
2000年後台積電與三星全面開戰
台積電是怎麼在這時突圍的
現在的台積電
真的取得完全勝利了嗎
上一集我們提到
孫運璿 李國鼎 張忠謀三個人
共同推動台積電的發展
將臺灣這個齒輪
卡進了世界科技業的核心
只能說
孫運璿與李國鼎獨具慧眼
在1960年代
從經濟與政治兩個方面
為臺灣找到了最佳的位置
政治方面
1960年到1970年代初期
美國深陷越戰的泥淖當中
1964年
中國也進行核試驗
臺灣當時的總統蔣中正
也正推行國光計劃
祕密計劃反攻大陸
亞洲區域當時其實很不穩定
美國急需一個
在東亞可以長期合作的盟友
岡山榮民蔴品製造工廠
是台灣新興的一項工業
利用本省盛產的瓊麻
加工編為繩索
供應國內外遠洋輪船運用
在經濟方面
1960年代
臺灣正巧在推動
勞動密集的出口導向產業
由於前十年進口替代政策
促使臺灣從農業轉向工業化
產生大量產能
開始在內銷出現產能過剩
因此
在1960年代改為出口導向
用龐大低廉的勞工
吸引美國等工業先進國家來臺投資
因應他們國內工資上漲產生的問題
政府積極設置加工出口區
以電器 紡織 塑膠等輕工業為主
此時
若能再拉上德州儀器的張忠謀
來臺發展半導體產業
那麼 天時地利人和就都有了
在南韓 新加坡 馬來西亞
都陸續加入半導體戰局時
臺灣也才有機會插一腳
但台積電遇到的挑戰才剛開始
台積電1987年創立
1994年在臺灣證券交易所掛牌上市
隨著營運步入軌道
下一個面臨的挑戰
就是要與其他半導體廠競爭
例如三星與Intel
在這塊市場上
大家競爭的不止有產能
更比誰能做出更小的電晶體
能在一塊晶片上塞進更多
但當電晶體開始縮小
問題很快就出現了
我們複習一下
電晶體的作用就是一個小水閥
可以透過一連串的開與關
組成複雜的邏輯電路
這個小水閥在電晶體中
稱為閘極 水閘的閘
而入水管跟出水管
分別稱為源極與汲極
源極跟汲極
像是兩個分別位於河川上下遊的蓄水池
若希望將源極的水輸送到汲極
則需要打開由閘極控制的水閥
其中
在邏輯晶片最常見的電晶體構造中
閘極是由
金屬 氧化絕緣層
半導體組成的夾心結構
因此這樣的電晶體
也常被稱為MOSFET
這樣的結構是單一個電晶體
但現在台積電已經能在單一晶片上
塞進兩千億個這樣的小電晶體
很快這個數字還預期突破一兆
要怎麼做
很顯然
唯一辦法就是縮小電晶體的大小
但是電晶體縮小
遇到的第一個問題就是
這個水閥會漏水
一般來說
電晶體的水閥
都會設定能關得很緊
抵擋橫向的水壓
也就是施加在閘極的垂直電場
必須遠大於源極與汲極間的橫向電場
若是在水閥關上時
無法完全阻絕電流通過
讓水溢流而出
輕則讓電路更耗電
手機得隨時掛個行動電源
嚴重呢就是水閥失去開與關的差別
徹底躺平
整個電晶體等於失效
當電晶體變小了
電路中所使用的驅動電壓
卻仍維持在0.7伏特左右
相當於閥門變小了
但水壓還是一樣大
因此閥門
最終會阻擋不了
溢洪道的水流產生漏電流
不只漏水啊
當源極與汲極距離縮短時
各種短通道效應
就像年歲漸長的老人一樣
慢性病不斷增加
這包括速度飽和
寄生BJT
熱載子效應
臨界電壓下降現象等等
就像看著健康檢查表上紅字的醫生一樣
工程師們好頭痛
面對電晶體微縮的極限
我們有什麼好方法嗎
為了改善短通道效應這個慢性疾病
學界 業界通力合作
提出了許多辦法延續摩爾定律
例如半導體是通過在矽裡面摻雜
摻雜其他元素所製成的
為了精準抑制漏電流
材料學家嘗試在電晶體的不同位置
摻雜不同元素
就好像製作羊毛氈
將不同顏色的纖維
塞到指定的地方
這種方式稱為離子佈植
沒想到做半導體
也要略懂手工藝啊
另一種方法是
減薄電機體中的氧化物絕緣層
讓垂直電場更容易穿過閘極通道
加大水閥的控制力度
然而
當絕緣層的厚度小於3奈米時
閘極也開始因為量子穿隧效應
產生了漏電流
雖然橫向的問題解決了
但本來應該阻絕水流的閥門
哇咧
現在卻自己開始漏水了
為了解決這個問題
Intel於45奈米製程節點時
選擇更換絕緣層的材料
從二氧化矽
換成了擁有更高介電係數的二氧化鉿
大幅降低了閘極漏電流
這個技術受到各大半導體廠的青睞
爭相開發且沿用至今
然而即使經過這種種努力
當電晶體繼續縮小
到了約20奈米左右的節點
這些做法又開始顯出疲態
而且過多的摻雜
不僅提升了製程的複雜度
還會使得元件效能下降
最後突破這個瓶頸的
靠的是一種全新的電晶體結構
鰭式電晶體
FinFET
原本電晶體的結構
可以想像成是一個2D的平面
源極跟汲極
都是嵌在平面基板上的半導體材料
而閘極從上方施加電壓
也就是說
這個閘門只能從上面往下關
當閘通道變得很短
這個閘門就關不太緊
當時日本日立中央研究所的久本大
想到一個辦法
如果改變電極的形狀結構
那閘門或許就可以同時從三個方向關上
也就是讓原本平面的電極
變成一片片垂直立起的魚鰭
而閘極則跨坐在立起的閘通道上方
這樣一來
閘極就可以從上方還有兩側
接觸到閘通道
形成一個ㄇ字型的閘門
當我們想要把閘門關上
閘極的電場就可以從三個方向
把閘通道緊緊掐住
這種結構的閘極
仍然是金屬
氧化絕緣層
半導體的MOSFET結構
閘極的金屬與薄薄的氧化層
會夾住連接源極與汲極的
半導體鰭片通道
這種像是魚鰭一樣的立體設計
往後便被廣泛稱為鰭式電晶體
當時
久本大找上了
加州柏克萊大學的團隊一起研究
畢業於台大電機系
正任教於美國加州大學
柏克萊分校的胡正明教授
就是團隊的其中之一
而且根據久本大回憶
FinFET這個名字
就是胡正明教授想到的
胡正明教授的研究團隊
1998年發表了
17奈米的FinFET
成功突破了當時晶片微縮的困境
FinFET
能夠在閘通道很短的情況下
依舊將閘門關緊
更短的閘通道代表了更快的開關速度
而且閘極
在運作時所需要的電壓
也比較小
用起來更省電
不止如此
3D的結構讓電晶體
可以往垂直方向發展
讓設計者可以更有效
運用晶片上的空間
FinFET
在效能跟面積效率上都具有優勢
因此席捲了全球的晶片產業
開啟了FinFET稱霸的10年
自從2014年以來
市面上17奈米以下的製程
大多是使用鰭式的設計
甚至一直到近幾年量產的5奈米
跟3奈米製程
台積電
也還是持續沿用同樣的鰭式架構
而台積電能夠在這段時間內強勢崛起
一部分也是靠FinFET技術的獨門優勢
而胡正明教授就是在2001年
受到張忠謀董事長的邀請
回到臺灣
擔任台積電第一任技術長
將FinFET的第一手技術帶回臺灣
這時候的台積電跟三星
正處於晶片戰爭激戰最前線
當時蘋果從iPhone的第一代晶片開始
就將晶片生產的訂單
全部交由三星完成
然而三星跟台積電不一樣
不只生產晶片
自己也設計晶片
蘋果赫然發現
三星自家發表的S5PC100處理器
內核竟然與蘋果委託三星生產
用在iPhone4上面的
A4晶片一模一樣
不只如此
三星Galaxy的手機 平板
也涉嫌抄襲iPhone跟iPad
這怎麼吞的下去呢
蘋果最後與三星撕破臉
2011年4月15日
蘋果對三星在美國
北加州聖荷西聯邦地方法院
發起侵權訴訟
訴訟一打就是7年
最後三星賠蘋果5.39億美元
和解收場
台積電當然不會錯過這個機會
張忠謀一開始
讓台積電只做晶圓代工
不做IC設計的策略起了效果
因為台積電不會打造自己的品牌晶片
因此沒有人會擔心
台積電剽竊他們的IC設計
再加上
台積電的20奈米製程良率
確實領先全球
蘋果在推出iPhone 6時
決定將A8晶片的訂單
交給台積電
你以為到這邊
就宣判台積電獲得完全勝利了嗎
不
僅過了一代晶片
情況突然再次迎來反轉
胡正明的學生梁孟松
竟然跳槽到三星
幫助三星搶先台積電半年
推出FinFET製程
是小於20奈米的14奈米節點
蘋果2015年發表的A9晶片
也變成同時交由三星與台積電生產
雙方直球對決的大場面
這場對決十年後的現在
FinFET的時代也即將迎來尾聲
台積電 三星跟Intel等半導體大廠
都已經準備邁入
後FinFET時代
一場全新的晶片江湖已然展開
五年後的半導體領先者
還會是台積電嗎
2024年第二季數據
全球晶圓代工市佔率
台積電佔了62%
第二名的三星只有13%
大約只有台積電的1/5
過去十年
台積電靠著在FinFET的領先技術
成為龍頭
然而現在先進製程來到三奈米
FinFET 終於也遇到它的極限了
FinFET之後即將接棒的
是全新的技術GAAFET
又有誰能煉成這個賢者之石
掌握半導體的下一個十年呢
我們先把時間推回到1998年
當時 電晶體遇到微縮的瓶頸
無法再縮小了
日本日立的久本大
與加州柏克萊大學團隊
發表了FinFET設計
成功突破了這個困境
其中
柏克萊大學團隊中的胡正明教授
後來帶著FinFET的技術回到台灣
於2001年到2004年
擔任台積電首任技術長
深深影響了台灣半導體的發展
不過 這因緣還沒完
胡正明在柏克萊大學任教時
有位台灣學生叫做梁孟松
他回台後
也成為台積電先進製程研發的核心人物之一
然而梁孟松2009年離開台積電
先是到韓國三星旗下的
成均館大學任教
培訓企業半導體人才
緊接著 2011年
便正式加入三星晶圓代工
擔任執行副總
當時三星在20奈米的製程節點上卡關
輸了台積電一大截
也輸掉了
包含蘋果A8核心在內的許多訂單
梁孟松加入後
說服三星放棄20奈米節點
直接跳往FinFET的14奈米節點
最後
三星比台積電早半年宣布
FinFET的量產
一口氣反超台積電
2017年
梁孟松與三星結束契約後
又加入中國的中芯國際
出任聯合首席執行長
讓中芯在2020年
成為繼台積電 聯電
三星 格羅方德
和英特爾之後全球第六家
能生產14奈米製程節點的企業之一
至於梁孟松要被視為叛將
還是如外傳
是被台積電錯誤的人才管理逼走的
我們難以判斷
但這起人才流失
無疑足夠撼動臺灣的經濟命脈
對需要維持「矽盾」堅實存在的我們來說
是個不可忘記的重要警惕
還好這次的事件結果
和許多人印象中的一樣
並沒有那麼糟
蘋果原本將A8處理器晶片
全部委由台積電生產
但因為三星提早成功研發14奈米製程
而台積電比較晚才完成
FinFET 16奈米的製程節點
因此下一代的A9處理器
蘋果選擇交由三星和台積電共同生產
結果是
兩間公司生產同一款
一模一樣的處理器
台積電的晶片
卻明顯的比三星還要好
許多人拿到手機一測
都發現台積電晶片的續航時間更長
蘋果還跳出來滅火
強調兩款CPU的續航力
只差了2%到3%
還把可以檢查CPU型號
判斷是三星
還是台積電生產的APP給下架
這場直球對決
突然讓台積電大獲全勝
影響的結果是
是從A10處理器
到我們製作影片時
最新的A18 pro處理器
還有到M4為止的所有M系列晶片
蘋果全部都交給
台積電一家公司全權生產
補充一下
我們說幾奈米的製程節點
早期的確代表的是
閘極通道的長度
然而後來台積電跟三星
所謂的16 14奈米
卻與閘極通道長度無關
因為當代先進製程
更多是透過FinFET等新結構
來提升效能
縮小體積
如果只看閘極通道長度
會遠比這個長度還要長
不管是16奈米
14奈米
甚至現在大家講的
3奈米
2奈米
它更像是一種「產品名稱」
越小的製程節點
代表在「PPA」法則中的指標
不斷被突破進步
也就是更低的功耗
更高的性能
以及更小的面積
但不管如何
屬於FinFET的時代
也即將迎來尾聲
當晶片產業發展來到5奈米以下
FinFET也開始出現了
以往平面晶體的漏水老毛病
效能開始走下坡
台積電 三星和Intel等半導體大廠
都已經準備邁入後FinFET時代
不過問題來了
在FinFET上
我們的閘極已經從三個方向
把通道給圍住了
這還想要我怎麼樣呢
很簡單
三面包夾不夠
你不會用四面嗎
如果有三個閘門解決不了的問題
那就用四個
當FinFET的閘門
從上方跟兩側同時關上
依然不行的話
就只剩閘通道的下方
可以下手了吧
把閘通道整個包覆在閘極裡面
讓閘門可以從上下左右
四個方向關上
這種四面環繞式閘門所打造的電晶體
稱為環繞式閘極場效電晶體
GAAFET
環繞式閘門可以在短通道的情況下
加強對閘通道的控制
此外
它的另一個優勢
在於可以將許多通道垂直堆疊起來
以往在FinFET中
如果想要增加電流
便需要平行排列好幾片的鰭狀通道
可是這樣
會增加電晶體在晶片上所占面積
造成電晶體密度的下降
在GAAFET中
我們可以將許多的通道堆疊起來
用同一個閘控制數個通道
這樣一來不只可以節省晶片面積
在設計時也更有彈性
可以說是完全發揮了3D的優勢
到了3奈米以下
FinFET的接班人
基本上就是這類GAAFET了
同時GAAFET
也能衍生出好幾種不同的構造
一般認為
3奈米與2奈米的先進製程競爭
會圍繞在奈米片Nanosheet上
這裡的奈米片
其實指的就是
被閘極環繞的這些片狀通道
將通道做成薄片狀
可以增加通道的等效寬度
讓更大的電流通過
在2奈米之後
可能會在1奈米製程出現的
則是叉型片電晶體
forksheet
在奈米片結構中
N型與P型上方的奈米片
需要維持一定的距離
改良的方法
就是在中間放上「介電牆 dielectric wall」
提升通道的等效寬度
這樣N型與P型電晶體就可以靠得更近
屬於奈米片的改良版
而GAAFET的最終型態
則是把所有東西都疊起來的
互補式場效電晶體
CFET
N型與P型電晶體在垂直方向
直接做堆疊
可能會出現在0.5奈米
也就是在5埃的製程節點以後
CFET也被認為是最完善的架構
有機會帶領半導體產業
前進好幾個節點
回到現代
台積電 三星 Intel 三家公司
都把2奈米 GAAFET 的初步量產時程
壓在2025年
也就是說電晶體全新時代
很快就要來臨了
其中
台積電稱他們的技術為
Nanosheet 奈米片
Intel將他們的產品取名為
RibbonFET
也就是「緞帶電晶體」
三星的2奈米節點
則命名為
MBCFET
Multi-Bridge-Channel FET
也就是多橋通道電晶體
雖然名字都不一樣
但基本上都是與奈米片
大同小異的結構
有了全新的電晶體結構
要能到實際應用
中間仍有不少挑戰
今天我們很高興邀請到盧志遠院士
來跟我們分享這個過程當中的複雜
院士你好
你好
想請教院士
我們看到GAAFET的形式有很多種
奈米線 奈米片 叉型等等
但如果目標一開始
就是要減少這個寬度
為什麼一開始就不發展
最窄的這個CFET的形式呢
所以你今天講
它有各家公司
有的人是片型的 有的人是柱狀型的
有的是各種的
這個其實沒關係 這個都可以OK
這個最重要的是它某家公司
自己本身的製程技術在哪個地方是最專長
他就用這個地方來
達到同樣的目的 這就可以了
所以這幾家它都各有不同的樣子
但是它的物理原則是完全一樣的
所以其實各家各施本領
看誰能先達標這樣子
它製程上其實到底會遇到什麼樣的困難
這個困難其實是非常難的一個問題
你想
我們在四五十年前
如果我們講
這個FET
Field-effect transistor 的物理原理的時候
任何人
沒有這個工業經驗的
立刻都會想到
最好四面或者多面
都被你的閘極能夠控制住
那是最好
所以當初就應該在
四十年前就做這個
GAAFET的這種樣子啊
為什麼不能呢
因為要把它包起來這個工作
是非常困難的製程技術
那在當時不包
而產生的副作用
其實是可忽略的
所以大家就繼續這樣子用
用到這個產生副作用的效果
越來越比正效果還大的時候
就不能再堅持下去
所以一定要包起來
一定要包起來的時候
那麼就看怎麼包了
那每一家比如說 今天Intel 三星 我們台積電
要怎麼包
就跟自己傳統的製程
跟它的製程功力有關
但是只要你能夠包起來
都能達到同樣的效果
那在這樣子的一個製程下面
我們能夠達到我們目標的PPA嗎
PPA是容易達到
可是我們也都知道
從摩爾定律一路過來
其實是要達到
PPAC
還有一個C
這其實在製程上很複雜的一個做法
那cost就變高了
你沒有想到很好的辦法把cost不變高
或者甚至降低 並沒有
那這樣子一做的話那個cost變高
好像就讓摩爾定律
變成不完整的
所以有人說摩爾定律死掉
有人說摩爾定律殘廢
這都沒錯
因為到現在還沒有想到說
能夠把這個Power
就是PPA變得這麼好
C也變的好的一個方法
還沒有
那既然GAAFET的困難那麼多
在邏輯晶片好像很難達到
但為什麼好像聽說非邏輯晶片的世界
已經可以做到了呢
是的 非邏輯晶片
今天已經可以做到
三百多層這樣子堆疊上去
它的結果是三百多層
你看 如果我們從這個模型看
這個模型一白一黑 一白一黑
一黑一白這一對
就是一個transistor
所以這等於說堆疊了這麼多層
我們就做這麼一個模型給大家看
但是這個東西的問題就在
要做邏輯的GAAFET
或者任何的FET他的這個Body
就是傳導的這個Body
必須要最好的單晶矽
要不然它的漏電
與它的性能（Performance）
就不能夠接受 在我們的應用上
可是在記憶體（Memory）
只需要是多晶矽（Polysilicon）
不需要是單晶矽（Single Crystal Scillion）
所以它就可以實現了
所以說 現在看起來CFET好像是
這個半導體製程的最終解法
那它能夠幫助
我們其實一直很想延續的摩爾定律
繼續它的下一春嗎
CFET如果說是最後一個
不如講是
到目前想像
可以做到這樣子
達到的一定的境界
其實CFET如果要再一步步前進
那就要像記憶體一樣
你要疊
它疊100層
你是不是也要疊100層
我們一般講的CFET
才疊了兩層而已
只有兩層而已啊
你不是這麼多層
那疊這麼多層
以現在的製程方法
去做這個邏輯的話
那個PPAC的C啊
會指數爆炸
那更不能承受
現在就是說這個C不太好
我們已經不太敢講了
這不講了啊
如果你成本無窮的爆炸
就變那麼貴
那根本就是不能接受
所以現在這個地方
是不是最後
我認為不是
一定有人有辦法
想出來讓PPAC重新恢復的方法
OK 這怎麼樣的結構
什麼樣的材料
這個裡面其實有人也有討論的
這裡面就要用
二度空間的材料2D材料
用新的這種
奈米碳管（Carbon Nanotube）的材料
什麼樣的材料來做
使得這個東西繼續可以跟隨摩爾定律
但是這個東西又是茲事體大
在我們這個半導體換材料
從矽基換另外一個基
那是天大的事
這個是真的大革命
感謝院士的說明
看來摩爾定律短時間內
還不會終結
而雖然台積電目前看似佔了上風
但也一刻無法掉以輕心
感謝所有研究學者和工程師的努力
不斷推出新的技術
才讓這得來不易的矽盾得以延續
最後也做個補充
除了新技術和新材料之外
晶片效能的提升還有一個關鍵
就是先進封裝
例如台積電提出的CoWoS
就將邏輯晶片記憶體和各種晶片
都放在矽中介層上面
所有小晶片都封裝在另一個大晶片上
先進封裝的重要性
就好比我們前面介紹過
諾伊斯發明的積體電路一樣
之前呢 是把電晶體 電容 電阻
封在同一個晶片上
現在
則是把更多晶片封裝在一個大晶片上
對於晶片的效能提升有很大的幫助
沒有EUV
半導體產業就完蛋了嗎
這一臺要價1.81 億美元的EUV
不止身價昂貴
在晶片產業鏈裡面
也佔據樞紐地位
在美國晶片法案的限制下
ASML被禁止出口EUV機臺到中國
甚至連臺灣的EUV機臺內
都裝好了自動鎖死裝置
做了最壞打算
讓中國即使侵臺
也無法竊取這項技術
但到底為什麼這臺機器
全世界都搶著要
我們真的沒辦法
打造另一間ASML嗎
做晶片的關鍵技術
我們在1957年就知道了
晶片本質上就是在矽晶圓上堆材料
但是每一層堆砌的材料
都要透過蝕刻劃下圖案
再疊上下一層材料
反覆進行
為了確保晶片上的圖案正確
1957年
萊斯羅普發展了一套
「微影製程」方法
我們簡短複習一下
首先在晶圓上長出你要的材料
接着塗上光阻劑
下一個關鍵步驟是曝光
你必須準備好光罩
放在紫外光和你的晶片之間
光罩上方會有圖案
阻擋紫外線穿過
那些沒有被阻擋的紫外光
會讓光阻劑的化學特性產生變化
以負光阻為例
照射到紫外光的光阻劑
溶解度會因而改變
當用溶劑沖洗的時候
這些部分會被留下來
而因為光罩阻擋
沒有照到紫外線的部分
則會直接被沖洗掉
最後放入氫氟酸或其他溶劑
那些沒有被光阻劑保護的地方
就會被溶劑蝕刻
刻下你想要的圖案
到這邊
恭喜你一次微影製程完成了
你印上了第一層的圖案
接着 只要重複
一次次的循環
最後就可以在晶圓上
蓋出立體的晶片
而當我們想要做出更小的晶片
其中的關鍵是
如何在光阻劑上
留下更細小的圖案
過去
只要將光罩的尺寸縮小
就能不斷造出縮小版的圖案
但是當光罩
小到一定程度的時候
過去沒出現的繞射現象發生了
具體來說
當圖案的寬度
小於半個光波波長時
光波就會發生繞射現象
光波在經過狹縫時
不只會筆直前進
它會在轉角處轉彎
刻出錯誤的圖案
也就是說
雖然光罩可以不斷縮小
但如果要確保圖案的正確性
每個結構的大小
都無法小於曝光光源的半個波長以下
例如在公元2000年初期
當時使用的光源
是雷射
雷射的波長已經從
氟化氪(KrF)的248奈米
縮短為氟化氬(ArF)波長的193奈米
193奈米的光源
要應付現在7奈米以下的製程
絕對是力不從心
為了繞過這個物理極限
科學家嘗試透過各種方法來克服
例如浸潤式蝕刻或是多重曝光
浸潤式蝕刻
指的是在光源和晶片之間
塗上一層水或其他液體
改善光學路徑
這有點像
我們在使用高倍顯微鏡的時候
會在鏡頭和樣本之間
滴上一滴鏡油
多重曝光指的則是
將一個圖案分成多次拍攝
例如
如果有6條線123456要曝光
可以一次分為兩次
第一次拍135
第二次拍246
如此增加線與線之間的間距
就能儘可能減少繞射的發生
這些方法統稱為
解析度增強技術
RET
希望在波長不變的情況下
透過重新設計
拍出解析度更高的圖案
除此之外
因為繞射產生時
紫外線會隨著光罩與晶片距離增加
偏移越來越嚴重
1970年代
又有人直接將光罩放在晶圓上
與光阻劑直接接觸
以減少光罩與表面的距離
但是這種方法在曝光結束
光罩被提起來的時候
通常會沾黏光阻劑
並損壞晶圓
最後這個方案作廢
而是改為發展對準曝光機
透過精密設備幫助我們
可以細調光罩與晶片的距離
等各項參數
藉此減少繞射現象
在這些改進之下
雖然當時曝光的光源是193奈米
深紫外線雷射
DUV（Deep Ultra Violet）
我們竟然
還是一路挺進到7奈米的製程節點
值得掌聲鼓勵
不過到了7奈米以下
DUV終究遇到了瓶頸
科學家終究還是要
往更小的波長曝光邁進
你可能會想
改用短波長有什麼困難的
這困難可大了
例如光線必須透過透鏡來聚焦
但是一般的玻璃透鏡
會吸收短波長的紫外線
波長185奈米以下的紫外線
甚至會被空氣吸收
因此整個微影過程
必須在真空當中進行
繼續看下去
你就會發現困難的不止這些
無論如何
此時終於有人下定決心
要從193奈米
直接跳進到波長1/10不到
只有13.5奈米的
極紫外光 EUV開發
而這個耗費30年時光
數十億美元開發
至今
全球也只有一間公司達到的偉大征途
也就此展開了
在先前的節目中我們提到
微影製程設備商的領頭狼
不斷換人做
從萊斯羅普發明這套技術以來
德州儀器 珀金埃爾默 GCA
到1980年代的Nikon跟Canon
先後成為不同年代的關鍵廠商
最後在關鍵的1990年代
新的挑戰者ASML出現了
Nikon Canon 跟艾斯摩爾
成為競爭微影製程設備市場的三巨頭
而Intel的一個決定
打破了三足鼎立的局勢
當時的Intel跟美國政府主導的實驗室認為
日本的半導體產業正在快速發展
甚至許多原本屬於美國的業務
都被日本搶走了
如果真的要投資設備商
應該就要選擇較為中立的荷蘭廠商
因此
Intel決定與ASML牽手
開啟30年的漫長研發合作
雖然這項任務耗費的時間 財力 精力
都無比巨大
但巨額的投資
也註定讓ASML在30年後
站上無可撼動的微影製程龍頭地位
Intel希望ASML能開發出
13.5奈米的極紫外光EUV設備
好應付未來更小的製程節點
但光是要怎麼製造穩定的13.5奈米光源
就是一個極大的挑戰
因為我們找不到一個雷射管或電燈泡
可以直接發出13.5奈米的光
要發出EUV
必須製造「高能電漿」
作法是用高強度的雷射
打在標靶上
讓標靶瞬間產生高能電漿
並放出EUV
這項用電漿製造EUV的任務
ASML找了另一間雷射公司
西盟(Cymer)來完成
西盟的任務很不簡單
他們必須設計一套流程
利用二氧化碳雷射
轟擊金屬錫來製造EUV
最後
這個流程
絕對比點亮一顆燈泡要更難許多
首先金屬錫要化為一顆顆
直徑30微米的小錫滴
並且透過發射裝置
以時速300公里的速度
快速穿過真空的腔室
還沒完
接着用高功率二氧化碳雷射
連續命中同一顆小錫滴兩次
第一次的雷射負責加熱小錫滴
讓它膨脹
第二次
則會把它加熱到攝氏二十二萬度
形成一團滾燙的電漿
比太陽表面的溫度
還要高四十倍
這樣子這團高溫電漿
就會輻射出短波長的紫外線
也就是EUV
但是這也只是一個短短的EUV脈衝
如果要確保機臺穩定產生EUV
這個過程需要每秒重複完成五萬次
要完成這套轟擊設備
剛剛說的大概只能算1%的困難度
例如
光是要造出這道雷射
西盟就找上了另一間雷射公司
創浦(TRUMPF)
創浦花了10年打造這道雷射
最後每座雷射發射器
竟然都需要使用超過45萬個零件
為什麼要搞得那麼複雜
原來當雷射照射小錫滴之後
錫會被雷射轟擊成殘渣
影響後續EUV的產生
因此小錫滴必然需要快速移動
並且精準的控制雷射命中的次數
讓新的小錫滴能不斷進入反應腔內
穩定產生EUV光線
題外話
除了錫之外
當時他們也考慮過其他元素
例如能發出波長更短
只有11奈米EUV的氙電漿
但是氙發出來的EUV強度不夠
錫還是首選
講到這裡
我們也只解決了一半的問題
因為就如同所有微影製程一樣
那道光
最終需要通過一連串的鏡片組
照射到我們的晶片上
這部分最大的挑戰
就是EUV很容易被其他物質吸收
那為了避免EUV跟空氣反應
而把環境抽成真空
大概是其中最簡單的步驟
因為連鏡片本身都會吸收EUV
頂級的設備
當然要由頂級的公司出場
來自德國的光學鏡片龍頭公司
蔡司 承接下了這項任務
首先
他們必須排除使用透鏡折射對焦的方式
因為EUV只要穿過鏡片
就會因為被吸收而大幅衰弱
因此UV機臺當中
是全部由反射鏡組成的
全反射式系統
但雖然改成反射式
還是要解決EUV會被吸收的問題
最後蔡司在鏡片上
鍍上矽和鉬兩種薄膜
這兩種材料
這兩種材料互相交疊數十到一百次
這種構造稱為
布拉格反射鏡Bragg Mirror
當光線在不同折射率的材料中前進
這個構造
能創造更多的反射與建設性干涉
提高反射率
作法是有
但這項任務實際上
還是太太太太難以達成
本集感謝台灣米銥贊助
讓我們能一窺人類工藝技術的極限
為了讓EUV能精準地照在目標位置
這些鏡片必須非常非常平整
有多平整呢
如果把鏡片跟比例放大到
臺灣那麼大
那麼鏡片上的瑕疵
起伏高度只能容許在0.01毫米下
差不多是一根頭髮的寬度
而這光線聚焦的精準度
就等於你在地球上
拿雷射筆去瞄準月球上的一顆乒乓球
唯有這樣辛苦產生的EUV光
才能經過多次反射聚焦
精準穿過奈米級的光罩
落在光阻劑上
Intel的光學微影執行長
Mark Phillips
就曾經表示
EUV是人類製造過最精密的儀器
可以說是人類科技力的極致展現
歷史告訴我們
蔡司跟西盟
都成功完成了他們的任務
ASML從2006年
成功製作出第一臺EUV樣機之後
從此獨霸市場一直到今天
我們能看到另外一間
比肩艾斯摩爾的公司出現嗎
可能很難
這種規模的公司
與無數技術的創新跟整合
是需要花費數十年
與數十億美元投資
才能夠建立的
那反過來
我們該擔心ASML壟斷整個市場嗎
嗯 壟斷已經是事實了
但是ASML並不是單打獨鬥的公司
看完前面的介紹我們就知道
EUV機臺的誕生
還得歸功於許多企業與零件商的共同努力
尤其是打造錫滴轟擊設備的
美國公司西盟
和製作反光鏡的德國公司蔡司
ASML自己生產的零件只有15%
他們真正的關鍵技術是將這些零件
組裝成一臺能運作的EUV機臺
雖然ASML後來收購了西蒙
也入股了蔡司
但EUV絕非一間企業或一個國家
就能獨自完成的
EUV
就是一臺
由多個國家與企業
共同打造的工藝品
時間來到現在
ASML已經瞄準兩奈米以下的製程了
在去年推出了最新的
高數值孔徑EUV機臺
並將第一臺賣給了Intel
傳聞台積電也已經入手了EUV機台
但還是屬於機密事項
這部份我們就拭目以待吧
你知道嗎
AI晶片再怎麼強
也可能輸在交通問題
想像一下
你打造了一顆地表最強AI處理器
效能爆表啊
但當它要把數據傳出去
卻卡在出口
傳輸的速度跟不上運算的速度
結果呢
就像用賓士引擎配腳踏車的車輪
把引擎的優勢整個拖垮
所以現在所有人都在瘋一個新解法
矽光子
從台積電、輝達、Intel
到歐洲的PhotonDelta
台灣的日月光、華星光
全部殺進這場讓光取代電的革命
甚至還聯合起來
組成了矽光子產業聯盟
和 HiSPA 國際矽光子異質整合聯盟
誓言要改寫AI運算與資料中心的傳輸未來
但矽光子到底是什麼
它真的有可能顛覆半導體世界
甚至台灣的半導體優勢嗎
今天我們就來解密這場
晶片界的光速革命
因為看懂矽光子
才算真正站在 AI 世代資料傳輸的浪頭上
為了在半導體市場取得先機
所有半導體廠都卯足全力
研發更小、指令處理速率更快的晶片
前面我們花了好幾集
介紹過去和未來要如何縮小電晶體
但除了電晶體本身之外
晶片上還有另一個會影響速度的關鍵
就是用來傳輸訊號的線路
1959年快捷半導體與Intel
這兩家公司的共同創辦人
羅伯特諾伊斯博士
提出一種新型積體電路
稱為單晶片積體電路
能把電路板上
電晶體、電阻、電容等各式電子元件
都整合在同一片晶片上
並在晶片上
以平面製程的金屬線相連結
這就是我們常聽到的積體電路 IC
因為半導體製程技術
與積體電路概念的出現
我們終於能讓所有元件
跟著電晶體一同縮小
現在當電晶體越來越小
積體電路內
各電子元件之間的連接線路
也不斷微縮
然而一旦想把金屬線路做得更細
電阻就會變大
產生訊號損耗和發熱等問題
此外金屬線路之間存在的電容
也會讓響應速率變慢
於是就算積體電路本身的製程技術
不斷突破
遲早還是會遇到
電訊號傳輸的物理極限
另一方面
隨著人工智慧和物聯網的時代到來
晶片間快速傳輸大量數據的需求
也指數性的上升了
像是Open AI或是Google
這種提供相關服務的公司
就需要一個...
欸 不是
是好多好多個龐大的資料中心
來處理並儲存來自全世界的資料
資料中心內部的資料流通量
往往是使用者端的數十甚至百萬倍
改善內部的資料傳輸
就成了資料中心實現高速運算
非得克服的關卡
想要提升晶片之間
以及伺服器、儲存
與網路設備之間的傳輸速率
方法就是把電訊號轉成光訊號來傳送
就像我們早已經把網路線路
從電纜改成光纜
就是希望用光來傳送訊息
用光來傳輸訊號的好處可不少啊
包括更大的傳輸頻寬
以及更長的傳輸距離
光纖能提供的頻寬
在短距離的訊號傳輸應用上
通常是銅線的10倍以上
而且光通訊
還能橫跨數百乃至數千公里的距離
像是海底光纜
途中每公里的訊號強度損失非常低
那既然光通訊那麼香
還不趕快把晶片上面的連接線
全部改成光纖
讓傳輸速率跟資料量
來個歐拉歐拉歐拉的提升呢
因為現實當然沒有那麼簡單
常見的光纖
是用玻璃或塑膠這類的透明材料
作為核心
外面包覆折射率較低的一層材料
這種結構
可以讓光波以全反射的方式
在光纖中傳播
才能沿著光纖左彎右拐
平常當做長距離傳輸的網路線
用起來沒什麼問題
不過光纖這麼大一條
根本沒辦法放在小小的晶片上
要如何在矽晶片上
用微米和次微米元件來操控光
就是矽光子這門學問研究的主題
好消息是
矽雖然會吸收波長1100奈米以下的光波
但對於一般光纖通訊所使用的
波長1100奈米以上的近紅外光來說
是完全透明的
也就是沒有光吸收的現象
這意思就是
波長在1100奈米上的光波
在矽中傳播
材料本身的性質
並不會造成光強度損耗
因此原則上
只要透過現有的半導體製程技術
就可以在矽基板上
做出數百奈米寬的矽波導
也就是類似光纖的構造
讓光訊號可以通過
這種微小的積體光路
如果和矽晶片上的積體電路
整合在一起
就可以縮小封裝尺寸
提升晶片之間的傳輸資料量
目前短距離的光連結
使用的是
已經有十多年歷史的
插拔式光收發模組
處理器計算完成後
送出電訊號
得先透過光收發模組中的
發射器光學次組件
轉換成光訊號
進入光纖傳送
再透過另一端的光收發模組中的
接受器光學次組件
轉回電訊號
這種光收發模組內
使用的是傳統的
雷射二極體做為光源
而且在接收端
必須先將光訊號轉換為電訊號之後
再送進伺服器或網路通訊設備內
這就像田徑接力賽一樣
訊號要在不同選手間交互傳遞
轉來轉去的
你也能理解
這使得傳輸效率仍有改進的空間
無法跟上AI時代爆炸性的資料需求
於是矽光子技術在訊號轉換上
雖然沒有改變
仍然必須經過電轉光
以及光轉電的過程
但是矽光子的目標
是將光通訊元件直接整合在晶片上
這可以減少對長距離電訊號互連的需求
大幅降低電訊號的傳播延遲和損耗
這就像是用高速子彈列車
取代擁擠的城市道路一樣
數據傳輸速率更快更遠
而且損失更小
要做到這點
就必須開發全新的
光子元件與封裝技術
有了亟待滿足的需求
矽光子的發展也就開始加速了
一個完整的矽光子光路
主要由四個元件組成
負責發光的雷射光源
將電訊號轉換成光訊號的調變器
傳送和操控光訊號的各型波導元件
以及將光訊號轉為電訊號的光接收器
現在研究人員的目標
就是將這些光子元件
用成熟的半導體製程技術
製作與整合在同一片矽基板上
並且與積體電路封裝在一起
不過在第一部光源的部分
就遇到了困難
單晶矽的材料特性之一
就是它的能帶結構屬於間接能隙
所以它的發光效率非常非常低
這白話文說
就是它沒辦法產生光
相較之下元素週期表上
在矽所在的第四族兩側
由第三族和第五族元素
形成的半導體化合物
與半導體合金
像是砷化鎵(GaAs)、磷化銦(InP)
以及鎵銦砷磷(InGaAsP)等
直接能隙材料
都是可製做出半導體雷射的
理想半導體材料
於是研究人員
需要將以三-五族為基礎的材料
或已製作完成的雷射二極體
鍵合或倒裝在單晶矽的基板上
這就是所謂的異質整合技術
異質整合有幾個途徑
其中一種是透過覆晶技術
在雷射二極體晶片上面
直接先做好電極焊點
然後把晶片翻過來焊接
或用直接金屬鍵合等方式
連接到矽光子晶片上的電路接點上
這種構造稱為直接安裝式雷射
而這種整合方式則稱為
混合式整合
雖然成本較低
但是要讓雷射二極體
對準矽波導中心位置的難度也較高
另一種常見的作法
則是在矽晶圓上
先將波導元件製作完成
然後將三五族雷射材料
和矽光子晶片
直接鍵合在一起
接著在三五族材料上
進行蝕刻、金屬化和鈍化等步驟
製作出雷射二極體
這種構造稱為
異質整合雷射
或異質矽光子雷射
因為是先將三五族材料
與矽光子晶片接合好之後
才以半導體製程技術
做雷射二極體與光波導之間的對準
跟前面介紹的覆晶技術比起來
省去了整合雷射與矽晶片時
需要拾取、放置雷射晶片
再對準的麻煩
此外有人提出了
在矽基板上先長出鍺虛擬基板層
再長出鍺錫合金
這種做法可以製作出雷射二極體
還有一派認為
這些整合工程實在太麻煩了
不如就把雷射二極體
放在矽光子晶片外頭吧
這樣還可以避免矽光子晶片過熱的問題
雖然不同的雷射二極體
與矽光子晶片整合方法
在不同的應用中各有優勢
但透過晶圓鍵合的異質整合技術
是目前公認在大規模矽光子整合中
最廣泛採用
也最有前景的解決方案
除了光源之外
矽光子在發展時曾遇到的另一個難題
就是從電訊號轉換成光訊號這個步驟
簡單來說
就是要能將電訊號的高電壓與低電壓
用光的明與暗來表示
才能用光來傳遞資訊
あの 聽起來沒有很難
不就是在高電壓的時候
把雷射光源打開
低電壓的時候關起來嗎
欸 首先
直接調變的雷射有一些
嗯...
先天的缺點不容易克服
例如直接電流調變
會造成較大的熱效應
與雷射波長偏移等等
另外這種可以直接調變的雷射
雖然調變頻寬已經可以達到10GHz以上
但仍低於外部調變器
可達到的調變頻寬
什麼是外部調變器呢
一般而言
當用高於雷射閾值的穩定電流偏壓時
雷射二極體會穩定持續出光
發出來的光是連續光波
透過在雷射二極體後方
加上一個可以用電訊號控制的光調變器
就能對波導中的光功率大小
也就是光的亮與暗進行控制
目前在矽光子中
調變器的基本原理是這樣的
本質矽半導體
也就是無雜質的純矽裡
如果有電子與電洞的濃度變化
它的折射率就會產生些微的改變
因此只要把矽夾在
p型與n型半導體中間
就可以透過控制兩端的電壓
來調整中間本質矽半導體區域中
電子與電洞的濃度
進一步改變本質矽半導體區域中的折射率
可是改變折射率
跟控制波導中雷射光的亮與暗
又有什麼關係呢
這時候就要講到這個
微環形共振器
簡稱環形共振器或共振環
這個環形波導
跟原本光走的直線波導
並沒有接觸
它是靠著光波在環形波導中
是不是能產生共振
在決定光能不能通過直線波導
欸 你看
共振環有固定的共振波長
當共振環的共振波長
調整到剛好
與直線波導中的光波波長相等時
光波可以在共振環中
形成行進波共振
同時能量就會從直線波導
耦合進到共振環中
原本的直線波導中
就沒有光能通過
等於是關的狀態
那如果光在共振環中
無法進行行進波共振
直線波導中的能量
就不會被共振環拿走
等於是開的狀態
接著 別忘了
我們可以用改變環形矽波導中的
電子電洞濃度
去控制這個環形波導的折射率
也就可以控制它的共振波長
所以我們甚至不用去改變
雷射光源的波長
只要把環形波導
夾在在p型和n型半導體中間
就可以微調環形波導本身的共振波長
進而達到對連續光調變的效果
這個環狀共振調變器
可以在幾十微米的空間內
達成高頻率的調變
Intel在2010年
就是利用這種設計
再搭配混合式矽雷射
推出了每秒傳輸速度50Gb
也就是每秒500億位元的光收發模組
成為矽光子商業化的先鋒
不過那已經是十幾年前的事了
從2010年到現在
矽光子實際發展的怎麼樣呢
Intel從許多年前
便已經瞄準資料中心內部
大量資料進出的需求
開始布局矽光子的研發與整合
他們目前也依然是這方面的領先勢力
2024年6月
Intel基於矽光子技術
發表了第一個
與Intel中央處理器共同封裝
並且完全整合的光學運算互連晶片單元
可以支援八個波長
在波導與光纖裡面傳輸
雙向傳輸數據速率
達到驚人的每秒4 Tera bits
也就是每秒4兆位元
其它像是Cisco、Broadcom、IBM等
美國大廠也都緊追在後
更別提一大堆大大小小的新創公司
和design house
也都想要分一杯羹
那台灣呢
我們雖然在積體電路的先進製程上
持續領先
但是因為積體光路的元件尺寸較大
所以其實不需要什麼五奈米
或三奈米先進製程
儘管在製程上沒有顯著的優勢
但是台積電和日月光等國內大廠
也意識到了矽光子的趨勢
最近幾年開始提出
相關的整合與封裝方案
在2025年3月
輝達推出矽光子網路交換器平台
便採用台積電COUPE
緊湊型通用光子引擎封裝技術
單一連接埠傳輸速度達每秒1.6 Tera bits
可以透過不同的連接阜配置
如 512 個 800 Gb/s 連接阜
或 2048 個 200 Gb/s 連接阜
實現 400 Tb/s 的數據吞吐量
支援跨地連接數百萬顆GPU的AI工廠需求
台積電的COUPE使用了自家的
SoIC-X 封裝技術
將電子IC堆疊在光子IC上
藉由垂直整合的方式
實現最高的能源效率
而封裝霸主日月光呢
則是推出了扇出型堆疊封裝技術
為矽光子的封裝提供新的解決方案
矽光子
雖然是這一兩年才躍上科技新聞版面
但背後的技術與原理
可是歷經了數十年的開發
未來也很有可能像電晶體一樣
成為科技發展的核心技術之一
而且不只有矽光子
在整個半導體產業的每一個環節
都有台灣的企業持續努力
從線寬更小的製程
到全新記憶體結構的開發
由半導體產業張開的矽盾
需要不斷創新的技術來維持
進入AI時代的我們
此刻回望過去
會發現若不是巴貝奇的遠見
蕭克利的堅持
八叛徒的闖盪
諾伊斯的領導
以及張忠謀等企業家的雄心與無畏
我們的科技不會走到今天
現在保護著台灣的矽盾
正是過去無數前驅智慧與勇氣的結晶
對台灣來說
半導體不僅僅是一個產業
它更是國家競爭力的核心
因此我們花了14集的時間
帶領大家回顧半導體產業的前世與今生
至於未來半導體產業
還會有哪些進步
又將創生出哪些新興科技
還會有哪些名字
登上矽文明的名人堂呢
嘿 或許就是你啊
畢竟台灣可是頭號玩家呢
如果你對台灣
在半導體領域的研究與發展有興趣
也可以搜尋、關注泛科學
與我們一起追蹤更多半導體的大小事
這個系列暫時在這邊告一段落
但是新的半導體競爭故事
將會持續展開
感謝你的收看
我們未來再見